Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Britlaff und ja, it's been a while. Wir haben ein bisschen
Zeit verstreichen lassen.
Die letzte Sendung war vom 6. November 2024 und drehte sich um die Ukraine.
Und heute haben wir den 9.
Februar, also drei Monate später.
Und die Sendung dreht sich um die Ukraine. Wie sollte es auch anders sein?
Und wie sollte es auch anders sein?
Begrüße ich auf der anderen Seite der Leitung, den Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo.
Ja,
es ist einiges passiert. Zur Erinnerung, also wir hatten die letzte Sendung,
gemacht, mehr oder weniger direkt nach der Wahl in den USA und haben schon ein
paar Gloomy Predictions gemacht, wie was sich denn so alles so ergeben könnte.
Das wollen wir natürlich dann auch ein bisschen überprüfen und ein bisschen
mal schauen, was da sozusagen von unseren Erwartungen übrig geblieben ist. Und,
ja, vor allem wollen wir aber dann erstmal so ein Battlefield Update machen.
Also euch mal so ein bisschen darüber in Kenntnis setzen, was denn eigentlich
in der Ukraine alles so passiert ist.
Und außerdem wollen wir so mal schauen, was auch noch um diesen Konflikt herum
passiert ist, was die Situation,
die internationale Situation speziell in der Ost betrifft.
Und da müssen wir natürlich über die USA reden. Gar keine Frage.
Das wird uns ein bisschen Schmerzen bereiten, aber hilft ja nix. Ne?
Ja.
Hast du noch initiale Anmerkungen?
Ja, ja, nee, es ist halt wie es ist.
Es ist halt wie es ist, genau. Ja, dann schauen wir doch erstmal so ein bisschen,
was passiert ist und wie beim letzten Mal kann man sagen,
es passiert ja die ganze Zeit etwas, Der Krieg geht voran.
Man kann aber natürlich auch das genauso beschreiben mit, es ist so ein bisschen Business as usual.
Das heißt, im Großen und Ganzen blicken wir nach wie vor auf dieselbe Situation
wie noch vor drei Monaten.
Das bedeutet, Russland wirft derzeit alles nach vorne, was es irgendwie hat.
Und erzielt, naja, also ich weiß nicht, ob man von Erfolgen sprechen kann,
aber so, sie drücken halt nach wie vor die Ukrainer langsam über die gesamte Front ein wenig zurück.
Das sind jetzt alles keine unfassbar großen Gewinne,
die dort gemacht werden auf dem Schlachtfeld, Aber grundsätzlich hat sich an
der ukrainischen Taktik, den Russen sozusagen eher defensiv zu begegnen, nicht viel geändert.
Warum sie das machen, haben wir ja auch schon mehrfach besprochen.
Das liegt an vielen Gründen. Das hat was mit der generellen taktischen Ausrichtung der Armee zu tun.
Das hat damit zu tun, dass die Angreifer immer sehr viel mehr Aufwand treiben
müssen als die Verteidiger.
Während den Russen ja offensichtlich das Leben ihrer Soldaten vollkommen egal
zu sein scheint, ist das halt in der Ukraine ganz anders.
Von daher ist es immer so ein bisschen dieser Trade für Land, für Abnutzung.
Generell ist es halt noch ein Abnutzungskrieg, nur dass sich die Länder eben
unterschiedlich stark abnutzen und unterschiedlich aufstellen.
Die Russen werfen nach wie vor viel Personal nach vorne, so sie eben noch welches haben.
Das wird immer schwerer, dann gehen wir gleich noch drauf ein.
Während die Ukrainer parallel eigentlich eher versuchen technologisch aufzurüsten.
Also sie antworten in zunehmendem Maße mit Technologie, setzen auf ihren Drohnenkrieg
und erzielen dort auch einige Erfolge.
Was ist jetzt konkret passiert?
Also es gibt über die gesamte Ostfront Kämpfe.
Das sind also nach wie vor diese Hotspots Chassifjahr, das ist diese Stadt hinter
der Stadt Bachmut, wo die Russen ja schon ein Jahr gekämpft haben, um die einzunehmen.
Chassifjahr ist sozusagen die nächste Siedlung, wo die Russen jetzt schon auch
wieder ein Jahr dran nagen und unglaubliche Verluste haben.
Die Stadt ist deshalb so schwer zu nehmen, weil es dort quasi bergauf geht und
noch ein Fluss durchgeht.
Die Russen drücken in die Stadt, von der Stadt wird jetzt auch bald nicht mehr viel übrig sein.
Dann ein bisschen weiter südlich um Terni herum,
bei diesem Ostgiel-Fluss hatten die Ukrainer ja nach ihrer Offensive in der
Chakiv-Region, wo sie diese riesigen Geländegewinne gemacht haben,
also dieser erste große Vorstoß vor zwei Jahren, der zweite war ja dann im Süden bei Kherson,
hatten sie quasi die Russen über diesen Oskelfluss hinaus verdrängt.
Jetzt haben also im letzten Jahr die Russen dort wieder ein paar Kilometer gut
gemacht, aber auch das sind keine riesigen Fortschritte.
Und wie auch schon zuletzt angesprochen, die relativ wichtige,
strategisch wichtige Stadt Prokowsk, die ist jetzt also auch in zunehmendem Maße unter Bedrohung.
Das heißt, die Russen versuchen diese Stadt einzuzirkeln, haben dort auch glaube
ich gerade am meisten Personal versammelt.
Aber wie gesagt, das bedeutet halt immer, die Fortschrifte sind langsam und
die Verluste der Russen sind unglaublich groß.
Und die Verluste sind nicht nur groß in Bezug auf Personal, sondern auch auf Material.
Wenn man sich so die Berichte anschaut von der Frontlinie, dann ist es also
teilweise schon wirklich aberwitzig, mit welchem Gerät die Russen dort überhaupt
noch in den Krieg ziehen.
Also klar, hier und da gibt es noch Panzer und gibt es auch noch gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge, Truppentransporter, aber es wird also genauso viel mit Privatkarren,
Golfkarts, Motorrädern,
Eseln und Scootern versucht in irgendeiner Form Boden gut zu machen und die
meisten Soldaten machen halt alles zu Fuß.
Es werden einfach Wellen und Wellen von Leuten nach vorne geworfen,
die einfach zu Fuß versuchen, mit purer Quantität dort den Ukrainern das Leben
schwer zu machen, was sie dann auch tun.
Aber also die Verluste sind enorm mit den Zahlen, das ist ja immer so eine Sache
aber es ging halt bis zu 2000.
Russische Verluste pro Tag, so bei den Zählungen, die so veröffentlicht werden,
von denen man lange diskutieren kann, ob die jetzt stimmen oder nicht aber die
sicherlich in der Tendenz immer einiges aussagen und sich.
Bisher eigentlich immer wenn es Dritte gab die auch ihre Berechnung veröffentlicht
haben relativ gut mit dem gedeckt haben, was die Ukraine so publiziert.
Ja, außerdem gibt es ja noch die Region in Kursk, da wo die Ukraine vorgestoßen
ist und das ist jetzt ziemlich genau sechs Monate her, dass die Ukraine dort
in Russland eingewandert ist,
eingewandert, eingemarschiert ist, eingewandert.
So eine Migrationsbewegung, weil die haben sich da ganz gut niedergelassen und
die Russen haben Teile davon zurückerobert und das war es dann aber auch.
Also da ist relativ wenig passiert und tatsächlich gerade in den letzten Tagen
gab es nochmal eine kleine Gegenoffensive der Ukrainer, die immer wieder so
Truppenwechsel und Schwachstellen der Russen nutzen,
um dann immer mal wieder so ein paar Nadelstiche zu setzen.
Das sind auch alles keine weltbewegenden Änderungen, nur Tatsache ist,
auch nach einem halben Jahr ist es den Russen noch nicht mal gelungen,
die Ukraine von ihrem eigenen Boden zu vertreiben, geschweige denn halt in irgendeiner
Form die Oberhand zu gewinnen in der Ukraine.
Und das sagt natürlich eine Menge aus.
Sirsky, der Oberkommandierende der ukrainischen Streitkräfte,
meint seit bis Ende 2024 haben die Russen allein in Kursk 38.000 Soldaten verloren.
Und grundsätzlich ist es halt einfach so, dass in 2024 die Russen mehr Soldaten
verloren haben in diesem Krieg als in den ganzen zwei Jahren davor.
Und das ist schon irgendwie irre. Ich meine, dieser Krieg ist jetzt drei Jahre
alt und die Verluste steigen einfach immer weiter an.
Ja, und was wir aber auch sehen können,
dass die Verluste an Material bei den Russen in den jüngsten Tagen bis Wochen
eher zurückgegangen sind jetzt.
Und sich generell Verluste ein bisschen von Material hin zu Menschen auch verlagert haben zunächst.
Und aktuell geht beides wohl ein bisschen zurück, gerade was das angeht aufgrund geringerer Aktivität.
Aber Russland, das zeigen auch die letzten Erhebungen oder Open Source Zahlen,
wird das Material nicht ausgehen und Russland werden die Menschen nicht ausgehen.
Sie werden halt nur einfach runterfahren müssen.
Sie werden halt ihre Verluste einfach den schwindenden Reserven anpassen müssen.
Das heißt, sie werden sie halt strecken müssen. Und was wir im Moment sehen
können, ist scheinbar Anfänge eines Streckungsprozesses.
Und definitiv scheint es so zu sein, dass die Russen das aktuelle Niveau der
letzten Monate nicht mehr durchhalten können oder nicht mehr gewillt sind durchzuhalten.
So sieht das Bild aus.
Also dass Ihnen das Material nicht ausgeht, das würde ich so nicht stehen lassen wollen.
Bestimmtes Material geht Ihnen sehr wohl aus. Also es gibt Material,
wo sie keine großen Probleme zu haben scheinen.
Das sind also vor allem Raketen.
Da läuft ihre Produktion und da ist es gut. Bei Fahrzeugen sieht es schon ganz anders aus.
Also gepanzerte Fahrzeuge, hätten sie da kein Nachschubproblem,
würde man die ja überall sehen.
Aber tatsächlich setzen sie in zunehmendem Maße weniger davon ein und das wird
auch damit zu tun haben, dass sie weniger davon haben.
Die Produktion im Land ist nicht in der Lage, das, was verlustig geht, auszugleichen.
Das funktioniert nur, also die Neuproduktion, das funktioniert halt nur,
weil sie eben bis vor kurzem noch auf relativ große Reserven bis hin zu alten
Sowjetzeiten an Fahrzeugen zurückgreifen konnten.
Nur diese ganzen Lager, die entleeren sich halt in zunehmendem Maße.
Also es sind dort einfach immer weniger Fahrzeuge zu sehen. Das lässt sich ja
anhand von Satellitenaufnahmen belegen.
Es gibt diverse YouTuber, die regelmäßig mit den Spenden Satellitenbilder aufkaufen
und dann akribisch nachzählen.
Und die Schätzungen gehen schon so weit, dass also im Laufe dieses Jahres diese
Altreserven weitgehend aufgebraucht sein werden.
Da stehen zwar dann noch hier ein paar Fahrzeugkörper herum,
nur kann es dann natürlich davon ausgehen, dass sie als erstes nicht die schlechtesten nehmen,
sondern umso mehr sie rausnehmen, umso mehr sind es halt auch einfach irgendwie nur noch Wracks.
Ja, also sie kratzen jetzt langsam schon mit dem Löffel in den Tiefen des Fasses, wie in England,
in Amerika so sagen, scraping the bottom of the barrel.
Aber mein Punkt war mit nicht ausgehen,
ist, dass der Nachschub in vielen Bereichen geht zurück oder wird aufwendiger und teurer.
Ja, aber sie passen sich halt an, indem sie dann halt weniger angreifen und weniger verlieren.
Das ist mein Punkt, was ich meinte, dass ihnen die Waffen und Panzer nicht ausgehen,
weil je weniger sie werden, umso sparsamer gehen sie damit um.
Und mein Punkt war, dass wir jetzt die Anfänge eines sparsameren Umgangs mit
Material beobachten können,
weil offenbar zum einen das Material knapper wird,
zum anderen sie wahrscheinlich andere Versorgungsprobleme vielleicht mit Sprit,
vielleicht mit qualifiziertem Personal,
vielleicht mit anderen Dingen haben.
Aber auf jeden Fall sieht es so aus, als wenn sie...
Das nicht mehr aufrechterhalten können. Also die Angriffe in der Intensität
der vergangenen Monate, so können sie nicht mehr durchhalten und brauchen eigentlich eine Pause.
Genau, sie bräuchten eigentlich eine Pause. Es gibt verschiedene Thesen,
warum die Angriffe langsam zurückgehen.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass sie komplett aufhören zu kämpfen,
sondern sie machen das halt derzeit einfach nur noch mit so disposable Personal,
Setzen weniger Gerät ein und dass sie weniger Gerät haben oder größere Schwierigkeiten
haben, dieses Gerät ranzubekommen.
Das ist eine Erklärung. Es gibt aber
auch noch eine andere sehr griffige Erklärung und das hat damit zu tun,
dass die Ukraine jetzt seit dem Machtwechsel in den USA ihre Strategie nochmal geändert hat.
Und wir wissen ja, dass die Ukraine schon lange dabei ist, eine riesige Drohnenarmada aufzubauen.
Also die Army of Drones, das ist auch mittlerweile eine eigene Sektion innerhalb ihres Militärs.
Also die nicht bemannten Streitskräfte sind da sozusagen ein eigener Körper
und mit ihren eigenen technischen Möglichkeiten bauen sie sich in zunehmendem
Maße eine massive Drohnenproduktion hoch.
Das heißt, sie hängen da auch in zunehmendem Maße weniger von Waffenlieferungen
ab, sondern sie brauchen vielleicht Materiallieferungen, aber sie bauen sich
diese ganzen Sachen selber.
Sie haben unzählige verschiedene Raketen- und Drohnensysteme entwickelt und
auch immer wieder neue vorgestellt und zum Einsatz gebracht.
Und das ist halt mittlerweile so weit, dass sie sehr schnelle,
von den Russen in zunehmendem Maße kaum noch abzuwehrende Drohnensysteme unterschiedlicher
Art haben, mit denen sie bis zu 1700 Kilometer nach Russland reinreichen können.
Und das tun sie jetzt auch. Und das hat halt zwei Auswirkungen.
Erstens, sie haben es also geschafft, die russische Luftabwehr schon so weit
auszudünnen, dass es bei den Russen fast gar nicht mehr möglich ist,
ihre ganzen Standorte zu verteidigen.
Also es gab extrem erfolgreiche Luftschläge gegen Ölraffinerien überall im Umkreis
der Ukraine. Also bis, wie gesagt, 1500 Kilometer weit nach Russland.
Und es gibt mittlerweile auf den Ölraffinerie-Bingo-Karten fast nichts mehr,
was noch nicht schon mal getroffen wurde.
Und es gibt so einiges, was jetzt mehrfach getroffen wurde und zwar nicht nur
mehrfach innerhalb dieses Kriegs, sondern eben auch so hier zum Beispiel diese
Ölraffinerie in Rüazan, eine der größeren und in Volgograd,
da sind also mehrere, also die schicken dann immer so ein Shitload von Drohnen los.
Ja, diese fiesen Double-Taps.
Genau und dann machen sie so ein Double Tap, dann haben sie so diverse große
Öllager zerbombt, also sie haben ja da immer diese riesigen Ölspeicher,
davon haben sie dann zwei, drei erwischt, die brennen dann wie Zunder,
dann hat es irgendwie eine Woche gedauert, bis die Russen überhaupt in der Lage
waren, mal das Feuer zu schlagen.
Also dem Feuer in irgendeiner Form Herr zu werden oder es ist dann einfach ausgebrannt,
also nach einer Woche brannte es also einfach immer noch alles lichterloh und
diverse Öl-Raffinerien mussten auch den Betrieb einstellen und kaum war halt
das Feuer gelöscht, kam die nächste Armada und dann brannte schon wieder alles.
Und während sie halt vor einem Jahr oder so auch ab und zu mal immer wieder
solche Nadelstiche gesetzt haben, ist es mittlerweile so frequent und so nachhaltig
und so massiv und dann eben durch diesen Double und Triple Tap so,
dass sie jetzt also wirklich langfristig sehr große Produktionsbereiche runterfahren
und komplett ausschalten müssen.
Und das schafft natürlich jetzt ein Versorgungsproblem und zwar gleich auf zwei Ebenen.
Erstens, dieser ganze Sprit ist natürlich Sprit, den sie auch brauchen für ihre Fahrzeuge.
Also das ist sozusagen auch die primäre Nahrung. Also du kannst eine moderne
Armee ohne Sprit heutzutage einfach nicht operieren lassen.
Und wenn sie halt all diese ganzen Versorgungsquellen zum Erliegen bringen.
Dann ist das eine sehr gute Erklärung, warum wir auch weniger Fahrzeuge sehen
im Einsatz, weil einfach mal der Sprit nicht da ist.
Und der zweite Effekt, den das hat, und das ist auch der Grund,
warum es vielleicht die Ukraine bisher noch nicht gemacht hat,
es senkt halt die Einnahmen der Russen, weil Russland lebt halt im Wesentlichen von Sprit.
Und diese ganzen Ölraffinerien werden ja nicht nur für den Inlandsbedarf und
für den Kriegsbedarf genutzt, sondern sind ja dann eben auch für die Exporte
ganz wichtige Einnahmen.
Und nicht nur die Raffineriekapazitäten, sondern auch die Speicherkapazitäten sind nämlich relevant.
Denn eine Ölproduktion bedeutet, du hast halt Ölquellen, die hast du angestochen, da kommt das Öl raus.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht so wie so ein Wasserhahn, wo du sagen kannst,
es bräuchte mal ein bisschen weniger, es bräuchte mal ein bisschen mehr.
Sondern die müssen eigentlich die ganze Zeit irgendwie entnommen werden.
Und wenn du permanent von den Quellen etwas entnehmen willst,
dann musst du es auch irgendwo hin tun. Das Öl muss fließen.
Ja.
Das Öl muss fließen und das Öl muss vor allem auch irgendwo gelagert werden
und es sollte halt im Idealfall dann auch raffineriert und in weitere,
also entweder direkt in Tanker weiter verschifft werden oder eben in Sekundär-
und Tertiaprodukte umgewandelt werden.
Aber wenn diese ganzen Produktionskapazitäten und auch Lagerkapazitäten in zunehmendem
Maße jetzt von den Ukrainern zerbombt werden, dann bricht halt dieses System auseinander.
Und das hat halt, wie gesagt, konkret auf die Militärlogistik einen Einfluss,
aber es hat eben auch einen Einfluss auf die Möglichkeit Russlands Öl zu exportieren.
Und ähnliches gilt auch für die Gasinfrastruktur, die auch teilweise angegriffen wird.
Also in Zahlen bedeutet das wahrscheinlich,
dass aktuell so mindestens 10 Prozent, eventuell bis zu 20 Prozent der russischen
Raffineriekapazität aktuell offline gegangen ist aufgrund von ukrainischen Angriffen,
um da mal Zahlen irgendwo drauf zu packen.
Und das heißt, dass so 80 bis 90 Prozent der Produktion noch da sind.
Aber ja, die müssen halt von irgendwoher kommen jetzt, beziehungsweise Russland ist auch groß,
sie müssen jetzt von woanders her herangeschafft werden.
Und ja, also es sorgt auf jeden Fall schon für Probleme.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, die Ukraine muss natürlich auch das gesamte Land
mit Öl und Sprit versorgen und schafft es irgendwie.
Ja gut, aber die können natürlich andere Quellen auch aus dem Westen nutzen.
Russland hat nur seine eigenen Quellen.
Der Grund, warum sich die Ukraine da bisher zurückgehalten hat,
ist halt auch der, weil die beiden Administrationen ja immer gesagt haben,
mach das mal nicht, weil sie Angst hatte, dass der Ölpreis dadurch steigt.
Und wenn der Ölpreis steigt, dann ist das sozusagen innenpolitisch ein Problem. Ja.
Das Problem gibt es jetzt nicht mehr. Trump ist jetzt gewählt und deswegen dreht
die Ukraine jetzt hier irgendwie auch auf und ich gehe eher davon aus,
dass das jetzt so weitergehen wird.
Also wenn sie jetzt schon 20 Prozent der Produktion runtergefahren haben,
dann kann es sehr wohl sein,
dass wir so in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten mehr und mehr Angriffe dieser
Art sehen und dann kann es auch durchaus sein, dass die Produktion mal so um
30 oder um 40 Prozent gesenkt wird und dann wird es auch schon wirklich schwierig
für Russland, weil das eben auch alles immer bedeutet,
keine externen Einnahmen und in zunehmendem Maße logistische Probleme.
Neben den ganzen Öl-Raffinerien greifen sie ja auch in zunehmendem Maße noch
Standorte der Militärproduktion an.
Sie haben diverse Fabriken angegriffen, die halt so Rocket Fuel herstellen oder
andere wichtige Komponenten, Elektronik, Bauteile etc.
Also es ist einiges im Einzugsgebiet der ukrainischen Raketenreichweiten.
Und die Abhängigkeit von amerikanischen Waffen ist halt auch dadurch deutlich
reduziert worden, dass die Ukrainer jetzt in der Lage sind, mit eigenen Waffen
Long-Range-Angriffe zu machen und diesen Drohnen.
Von daher erwarte ich da eigentlich, dass wir in diesem Jahr sehen werden,
dass die Russen damit noch sehr viel mehr Probleme haben.
Es ist immer ein bisschen schwer einzuschätzen, wie intensiv das jetzt ist und
wie viel die Russen durch andere Maßnahmen gegenhalten können.
Aber man kann mal festhalten, gut läuft es nicht für die.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass die da jetzt gerade so einen Siegeszug haben
und das ist alles nur noch eine Frage der Zeit, sondern die Zeit arbeitet hier
eigentlich tendenziell eher für die Ukraine derzeit.
Es gab interessante Zahlen, die veröffentlicht wurden kürzlich.
Und zwar produziert die Ukraine wohl 33 Prozent ihres militärischen Bedarfs mittlerweile selbst.
40 Prozent kommen aus der USA und 27 Prozent aus Europa und dem Rest der Welt.
Also so verteilt sich das. Das fand ich halt auch interessant.
Ja, also mittlerweile ja ein Drittel ihrer Waffen produziert die Ukraine mittlerweile selbst.
Aber es zeigt halt auch, wie wichtig die USA sind, gerade was Waffen angeht.
Wobei Europa, da Europa ungefähr genauso viel Geld gibt oder eher tendenziell
ein bisschen mehr Geld sogar noch,
was dann mehr in die Unterstützung der Wirtschaft fließt.
Also Europa gibt mehr Wirtschaftshilfe als die USA, während aber die USA ja
40 Prozent der Waffen oder des militärischen Bedarfs aktuell gedeckt hat im vergangenen Jahr wohl.
Das ist aber schon eine ganze Menge. Also das hätte ich jetzt nicht für möglich
gehalten, dass sie schon so viel selber produzieren können.
Ja, aber es klang realistisch, die Zahlen und die Ukraine war ja auch,
es ist ja nun mal ein industrialisiertes Land, auch in weiten Teilen und groß und ich meine,
klar und hat ihre Wirtschaft natürlich jetzt massiv auf Waffenproduktion umgestellt.
Die Waffenproduktion selber mehr ausgeweitet wahrscheinlich als alle anderen
Länder sie ausgeweitet haben.
Und ja, das hat natürlich eine gewisse Vorteile oder die Hauptvorteile ist,
dass sie halt Waffensysteme produzieren können selber,
die keiner Reichweitenbeschränkung unterliegen beispielsweise Oder keiner Beschränkung,
welche Ziele sie irgendwie damit angreifen können.
Und das zeigt sich jetzt gerade, wie wichtig das ist.
Der Großteil der Drohnen der Langstrecken oder die ganzen Langstreckendrohnen
eigentlich sind ukrainische Eigenproduktionen.
Gehen wir doch nochmal kurz auf die Waffensysteme ein, von denen so berichtet wohl.
Das passt dann vielleicht auch ganz gut jetzt hier mal rein.
Nein, da gibt es im Prinzip eine Menge zu berichten.
Also Ukraine hat angekündigt, dass sie jetzt ihre eigenen ballistischen Raketen,
die RIM-2 in Produktion haben.
Und dann meistens, wenn sie das ankündigen, heißt es auch schon,
dass sie schon mal irgendwie geflogen sind. Und sie erhalten in zunehmendem
Maße jetzt auch eben Investitionen für diese ganze Militärproduktion.
Also da sind die Skandinavier ganz vorne. Ich glaube, die Schweden geben eine Menge Geld dafür.
Die Dänen vor allem.
Und die Dänen auch, die kaufen sozusagen Waffensysteme bei ukrainischen Firmen
oder geben die ihren Auftrag,
die dann anschließend an die Ukraine gehen.
Also so läuft das, die geben halt Geld und auch ein bisschen materielle Unterstützung.
Und ja, und da gibt es jetzt auch erste Ergebnisse, die da an der Front landen.
Also ich glaube auch unter anderem ein Artillery-System und die RIM haben wir
glaube ich vor ein oder zwei Jahren auch schon mal erwähnt im Podcast,
erinnere ich mich, weil das Ganze heißt nämlich übersetzt so viel wie Donner.
Also die Donner 2, kann man sagen, was ich mich recht entsinne.
Gut.
Je nachdem, welche Nomenklatur man wählt, ist es eine Rakete mit kurzer oder mit,
mittlerer Reichweite, auf jeden Fall mit vergleichsweise hoher Reichweite im
Vergleich zu den anderen Waffen.
Also ich glaube, das ist eine von denen, die bis 500 Kilometer und weiter geht.
Aber wenn ich mich recht entsinne.
Ja, 500 Kilometer. Man muss immer bedenken, ballistische Rakete.
Also sie haben ja Drohnen, die weit fliegen können, haben wir ja eben schon
gesagt, bis zu 1700 Kilometer weit.
Nur Drohnen fliegen halt langsam und können halt potenziell gut abgefangen werden,
wenn man denn eine funktionelle Luftverteidigung hat, was natürlich nochmal ein anderes Thema ist.
Aber hochgeschützte Bereiche wie Waffenlager und so weiter haben schon nochmal
die Möglichkeit sich zu wehren.
Bei den Raffinerien hat es jetzt nicht so gut funktioniert und auch irgendwie
Netze, die sie da installiert haben, das hat alles nicht viel gebracht.
Ballistische Raketen haben aber eben eine ganz andere Tragweite,
weil ballistisch heißt ja im Prinzip, du schießt sie eben sehr hoch mit hoher
Geschwindigkeit Und dann eben ballistisch,
also in so einer normalen Flugbewegung mit sehr hoher Geschwindigkeit schießen
die dann halt einfach nach unten und die kriegst du halt nicht so ohne weiteres abgewährt.
Das heißt, wenn du 500 Kilometer weit ballistisch ballern kannst und auch noch
eine gute Treffsicherheit hast, dann ist das definitiv für die beschossene Seite ein Problem.
Naja, die kommen dann mit, weiß nicht, Mach 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
also bis zu achtfacher Schallgeschwindigkeit fliegen ballistische Raketen in
der Regel, je nach Reichweite.
Ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall ein Fortschritt.
Ich hatte auch noch eine interessante Debatte gehört über die Frage,
warum denn die russische Luftabwehr eigentlich solche Probleme hat,
die Raffinerien jetzt zu schützen oder überhaupt, warum die Ukrainer es schaffen.
So viele primitive Drohnen sogar durchzubringen und das ist halt ganz interessant.
Weil da kommen mehrere Dinge zusammen.
Punkt eins ist, dass Russland seine Luftabwehrsysteme in der Nähe der Grenze
natürlich konzentriert hat.
Weil das Land ist groß und so viele haben sie nicht.
Deswegen ist sowas wie flächendeckende Luftabwehr nur in der Nähe der Grenze möglich.
Jetzt hat das aber ein Problem für sich selbst, weil du kannst halt diese Luftabwehrgeräte
nicht die ganze Zeit an einem Ort eingeschaltet lassen.
Weil wenn du da zwei oder drei Tage rumstehst irgendwo mit deinem teuren Luftabwehrsystem.
Dann kannst du davon ausgehen bis zu Toast.
Das sind natürlich keine Ziele.
Das heißt, was sie mit diesen Luftabwehrsystemen machen, ist,
dass sie ständig von einem Ort zum anderen fahren,
die kurz einschalten, gucken, was Sache ist und nachdem sie sie eingeschaltet haben,
das erste Mal tickt quasi auch die Glock und es wird immer gefährlicher,
an diesem Standort zu bleiben.
Das heißt, durch diese ständig notwendigen Verlagerungen öffnen sich natürlich
dann auch sowohl temporär als auch räumlich immer gewisse Lücken in der Flugabwehr, weil auch,
wie gesagt, die eben nicht die ganze Zeit an sein können und so.
Und dann, das ist der eine Punkt, dann tendiert die Ukraine dazu auch immer
dann mit einer größeren Zahl oft bis zu 100 Flugkörpern anzugreifen,
was halt schlicht dann auch für das Problem sorgt.
Selbst wenn sie die Dinger orten, kriegen sie einfach nicht alle abgeschossen
in dem Zeitraum, bis sie durch sind durch das Gebiet.
Und auf Seiten jetzt der Ziele gibt es auch dann öfter noch konzentrierte Luftabwehr,
weil die haben halt dann das gleiche Problem,
dass die jetzt nicht um jede Ölraffinerie hinreichend Luftabwehr hinpacken können,
dass die mit 20 gleichzeitig anfliegenden Drohnen oder so klarkommen oder auch
nur mit einer größeren Anzahl.
Und unterwegs, ich sag mal zwischen Grenze und dem eigentlichen Ziel im Hinterland, ist nichts.
Weil es einfach zu viel Land, da ist halt so gut wie keine Luftabwehr.
Und dann sind natürlich die modernen Waffen auch alle in der Lage,
sich ihren Weg zu suchen.
Das heißt, wenn da irgendwo was ist, dann ist das häufig bekannt,
wenn da was sendet und dann fliegen sie eben drumrum.
Und so erklärt sich halt die Problematik, warum Russland einfach prinzipiell nicht in der Lage ist,
diese Drohnenangriffe abzuwehren.
Also fand ich ganz interessante Sach- und Gemengelage. Und die Ukraine hat natürlich dasselbe Problem.
Aber in geringerem Maße, weil nicht so groß wie die Sowjetunion Russland.
Ja, also das stimmt alles mit der Luftabwehr. Es ist ein bisschen unklar.
Man weiß nicht so richtig, über wie viele funktionierende Systeme Russland eigentlich noch verfügt.
Also sie hatten davon sehr viel und mit Sicherheit sind sie da noch nicht an
das Ende ihrer Reserven gekommen.
Aber sie verlieren halt relativ viel und sie verlieren vor allem auch viel Artillerie.
Also es sieht so aus, als ob die Ukraine das Counter-Battery-Fire also sehr
gut optimiert hat. Das ist ja so ähnlich wie bei der Luftabwehr.
Also auch die Artilleriesysteme können halt sehr gut anhand ihrer Schüsse geortet werden.
Und wenn du halt einfach schnell darauf reagieren kannst und intelligente und
präzise Artilleriesysteme hast, und das hat die Ukraine ja,
dann kannst du eben auch schnell dafür sorgen, dass die dich angreifenden Artilleriesysteme
schnell zerstört werden.
In dem Zusammenhang ist es ganz interessant, dass die Ukraine ja jetzt das erste
Land sind, die die sogenannten RCH-155 aus Deutschland erhalten haben.
Das ist so die nächste Generation von Artilleriesystemen.
Wir hatten ja, glaube ich, schon mal über die Panzerhaubitze 2000 gesprochen,
die ja auch in der Ukraine zum Einsatz kamen und die auch schon sehr hohe Automatisierung hatte.
Und die, wenn sie schießt, extrem präzise ist, extrem weit schießen kann,
in der Lage ist, gleich so mehrere Geschosse hintereinander zu machen mit unterschiedlichem
Winkel, sodass man auch dafür sorgen kann, dass so eine ganze Barrage von Artillerie,
also so vier, fünf Geschosse gleichzeitig mehr oder weniger an dem selben Ort ankommen.
Also schießt halt den ersten ein bisschen höher und den anderen eben entsprechend
niedriger, dass sie kürzere Wege haben.
Und RCH 155 ist jetzt sozusagen die nächste Generation.
Und das ist halt ein Artilleriesystem, was sehr mobil ist.
Im Gegensatz zu der Panzerhubitze ist es halt auf Rädern. Genau.
Und das Besondere daran ist, dass es halt sehr hochautomatisiert ist und zwar
so sehr, dass es das erste Artilleriesystem ist, was extrem präzise ist,
aber während der Fahrt schießen kann.
Das heißt, man stellt sozusagen das Ding auf ein Ziel ein, fährt los.
Und jetzt hast du natürlich das Problem, dass du die ganze Zeit über den Acker
fährst und die Kanone fährt halt hoch und runter.
Und klar, heutzutage hast du ja bei solchen Tanks, beim Leopard,
auch schon immer solche Korrektursysteme.
Das heißt, die eigentliche Kanone bleibt sozusagen stabil, während der Rest sich bewegt.
Und hier bei dieser selbstfahrenden Artillerie-Maschine, dieser RCH-155, also diese Haubitze.
Da geht das halt so weit, dass sie dann sozusagen in dem Moment schießt,
wo die Kanone in die richtige Richtung zeigt.
Also die schießt nicht auf Knopfdruck mit jetzt, sondern man sagt so, ab jetzt schieß mal,
wenn du gerade in die richtige Richtung zeigst und Und kriege das halt einfach
hin in voller Fahrt oder ich weiß nicht, ob es in voller Fahrt,
aber auf jeden Fall in Bewegung zu schießen mit anderen Worten,
in dem Moment, wo das Ding schießt.
Ist sie im nächsten Moment schon woanders? Es dauert gar nicht erst nochmal
60 Sekunden, bis man sich dann weggeparkt und woanders hin bewegt hat,
sondern das Ding ist im Prinzip überhaupt gar nicht mehr so richtig zu orten.
Muss man mal sehen, in welchen Mengen das Gerät jetzt dort zum Einsatz kommt
und wie erfolgreich es am Ende wirklich ist, aber das ist definitiv nochmal ein Upgrade.
Ja und es braucht nur zwei Leute, das hattest du glaube ich nicht erwähnt,
Fahrer und Schützen im Gegensatz zu fünf Leuten, die du brauchst, glaube ich,
bei einer Panzerhaubitze 2000 und bei anderen mobilen Artilleriesystemen,
die aber überhaupt nicht automatisiert sind, also jetzt so LKW basiert,
hast du oft Bedienmannschaften von 12 bis 15 Leuten,
die halt, das heißt,
zwei Leute ist halt schon mal ein deutlicher Vorteil, auf jeden Fall.
Achso, gepanzert ist das Ding auch ein bisschen so, das heißt,
die sind jetzt nicht völlig schutzlos da drin.
Und ein interessanter Aspekt an dieser Automatisierung ist,
dass das auch ein Trend ist dann zu vollautomatisierten Artilleriesystemen.
Wo vor allen Dingen die Feueraufträge und die Koordinaten nicht,
gut, die kommen sowieso meistens von außen, die Aufträge, Da denkt sich die
Mannschaft jetzt nicht selber aus.
Aber was halt hier möglich ist, sind zwei Dinge bei diesen Artilleriesystemen jetzt.
Erstens, dass sie halt quasi integriert sind über entsprechende Datenlinks in
ein größeres System und im Grunde genommen ferngesteuert schießen.
Das heißt, da fährt jemand mit dem Ding in der Gegend rum und potenziell gesteuert
wird die Kanone quasi von außen.
Was natürlich auch noch weitere Automatisierung bis zu Drohnen hingeht,
dass du dann zukünftig nur noch ein Fahrzeug dort fährst und von drei oder vier
Robot-Artillerie-Fahrzeugen irgendwann mal begleitet wird.
Aber ja, interessant in dem Zusammenhang.
Auch noch ist, dass die Ukraine wohl flächendeckend jetzt oder natürlich nie genug,
aber mit Link 16 oder Link 16 NATO-Datenverbindungen ausgestattet sind.
Das ist so ein Link 16, das ist so der Standard, das ist so das verschlüsselte
Funknetz der NATO mit Frequency-Hopping und allem möglichen.
Der verschlüsselt auch auf Funkebene und die so 100 Kilobit bis zu 100 Kilobit
Durchsatz ungefähr machen können und wo alles mit allem reden kann.
Also auch teilweise Raketen und Flugzeuge und Schiffe und Panzer und also die
vernetzen da mittlerweile alles.
Und selbst wenn sie nicht während der Fahrt schießen, was natürlich ziemlich abgefahren ist,
ist auch die Schussrate so hoch, dass sie 5, 6, 7 Schuss abgeben können und
wieder losfahren können,
bevor die Geschosse eingeschlagen sind.
Und das kann jetzt nicht nur die RCH-155, sondern es ist generell so auch andere
neuere Artilleriesysteme sind dazu in der Lage zu schießen und sich vom Acker zu machen,
bevor die Geschosse auch nur eingeschlagen sind.
Und das ist natürlich auch ein riesiger Vorteil.
Ja, also die ganze Automatisierung, die nimmt enorm zu.
Es gibt mittlerweile auch extrem viele Ground-Robots unterschiedlicher Bauart,
also sowohl zur Versorgung der Truppen als auch schon bewaffnet mit Maschinengewehren und so weiter.
Also der Cyberwar, den wir uns irgendwie im Science-Fiction immer vorgestellt
haben, so Terminator-mäßig, der entwickelt sich dort langsam.
Und da ist die Ukraine definitiv weiter vorne als die Russen,
die sicherlich alles probieren, aber ich glaube nicht ganz so die Möglichkeiten
haben und nicht ganz so viel Druck haben,
das alles über Technologie zu lösen, beziehungsweise Schwierigkeiten haben in
ihrem korrupten System,
diesen Technologie-Pace überhaupt hinzulegen.
Während die Ukraine da sehr viel mehr wie so ein Rudel von Startups agiert,
haben wir ja auch schon mal drüber gesprochen.
Das zeigt sich eben auch in der Weiterentwicklung in anderen Bereichen,
zum Beispiel diese Naval Jones, ich weiß nicht, ob wir da letztes Mal schon
drüber gesprochen haben, die sie ja schon seit längerem im Schwarzen Meer einsetzen müssen.
Also quasi so selbstfahrende Boote,
die ja bisher eher so als Kamikaze-Boote verwendet wurden, die also mit Sprengstoff
beladen irgendwo hinfahren und dann explodieren,
womit ja diverse Schiffe und teilweise auch die Kertschbrücke angegriffen wurde
und Schiffe auch versenkt wurden damit, sehr erfolgreich in Häfen, aber auch auf hoher See.
Und mittlerweile bauen sie die Dinger aber quasi auch als fernsteuerbare Flugzeugträger aus.
Nicht um Flugzeuge damit zu starten, dafür sind sie natürlich zu klein,
aber ebenso FPV-Drones.
Es gibt also Berichte, dass sie mit diesen Naval-Drones das Krim-Ufer runtergefahren sind.
Jetzt nicht bis ganz zum Süden, aber so in dem nördlicheren Bereich.
Und dort dann vom See aus Drohnen gestartet haben,
die dann quasi über dieses Boot ferngesteuert wurden und damit dann Luftabwehrsysteme
zerstört haben. So etwas gibt es.
Und jüngst gibt es auch wohl eine neue Antwort, auch wenn noch nicht so ganz klar ist,
wie sie das machen, aber die Russen hatten ja sehr großen Erfolg durch den Einsatz
dieser sogenannten Gleitbombs.
Also normale, klassische Bomben, die man normalerweise einfach mit Flugzeugen abwirft,
die sie dann mit diesen Gleitkits ausstatten, also quasi so Flügelchen,
mit denen sie die Gleitbombs aus sehr hoher Entfernung oder sehr großer Entfernung abwerfen konnten.
Und die dann mit einer extrem hohen Sprengkraft bis zu 500 Kilo schwer sehr
nachhaltig Stellungen der Ukraine angegriffen haben.
Das hat so in den letzten Monaten, im letzten Jahr eigentlich den Ukrainern
am meisten zu schaffen gemacht.
Einerseits hat wohl die Ukraine jetzt auch entsprechende Gleitbombs im Einsatz,
die sie mit SO24 absetzen können.
Andererseits gibt es wohl neue Countermeasures, mit denen sie die Russen jetzt
besser verteidigen können.
Die Russen haben immer größere Distanzen geschafft, sind mittlerweile so, glaube ich,
können es schaffen, Gleitbombs mit bis zu 80 Kilometern Abstand abzuwerfen,
dass ja also die Flugzeuge nicht mehr im Range sind von den F-16 Flugzeugen
und sonstigen Luftabwehrsystemen.
Aber dadurch, dass die Gleitbombs jetzt länger unterwegs sind haben sie wohl
irgendein Trackingsystem etabliert
mit dem sie diese Gleitbombs dann sozusagen selbst tracken können,
was vorher schwierig war, weil die Distanzen noch nicht so groß genug sind aber
für 80 Kilometer müssen die auch eine Weile unterwegs sein und also auch da
tut sich was und es macht so den Eindruck, als ob die Bedrohung durch Gleitbombs
ein bisschen zurückgegangen ist,
Also es ist sehr viel in Bewegung. Was wir noch nicht erwähnt haben,
ist dieser verstärkte Einsatz von Lichtwellenleiter-Drohnen,
um diesen ganzen Electronic Warfare zu umgehen.
Also da werden die Drohnen losgeschickt und ziehen im Prinzip so eine Glasfaser
hinter sich her und werden darüber gesteuert.
Okay, das machen wohl beide Seiten. Ja und jetzt ist halt einfach die Frage,
wer hat da mehr Luft und mehr Atem und ist mit der besseren Technik in größeren Zahlen unterwegs.
Du hast ja mal da auch Zugänge und Verluste mal genauer angeschaut.
Ja, es gab kürzlich jetzt von Perun auch nochmal eine Auswertung von Open Source Daten,
was denn jetzt so Verluste und Zugänge von Waffensystemen in der Ukraine angeht.
Er hatte das vor einer Weile auch für Russland gemacht.
Das hatten wir dann, glaube ich, auch seinerzeit erwähnt.
Aber was die Ukraine angeht, jetzt was Panzer angeht,
gab es in 2022 und 2023 und 2024 auch größere Zuwächse.
Aber die Ukraine verliert so etwa 350 Kampfpanzer pro Jahr.
Also 80 bis 90 pro Quartal, sagen wir so ein pro Tag ungefähr. Ja.
Und hatte aber Zugänge von ungefähr 60 pro Quartal.
Das heißt, die Nettoverluste bei Kampfpanzern jetzt aktuell in den letzten Monaten
lagen bei 20 bis 30 pro Quartal.
Also da geht es dergleichen im Moment die Zugänge, die Verluste nicht ganz aus.
Und generell sind es auch für die Anzahl der Soldaten, die die Ukraine hat.
Hat sie viel zu wenig Kampfpanzer.
Sie bräuchte im Grunde genommen drei bis fünfmal so viele Kampfpanzer für die
Größe der Armee, wenn sie alle Einheiten so ausstatten würde,
wie sie buchmäßig ausgestattet sind.
Da ist natürlich die Frage, okay, womit kämpfen denn jetzt die Truppen,
die ukrainischen Truppen, wenn sie so wenig Kampfpanzer haben und die Antwort
ist so Armored Personal Carriers und MRAPs.
Also nur noch ein Panzerkampfwagen oder gepanzerte Fahrzeuge einfach so.
Und davon ist es so, davon haben sie bisher etwa 500 verloren und 1600 dazu bekommen.
Das heißt, netto hat die
Ukraine jetzt seit Kriegsbeginn 1200 mehr als zu Kriegsbeginn und diese Fahrzeuge
sind wichtiges Rückgrat der ukrainischen Armee auf jeden Fall.
Bei Kampfflugzeugen hat die Ukraine seit Kriegsbeginn ca.
120 verloren und 80 Kampfflugzeuge neu dazubekommen.
Das sind jetzt nicht alles Westliche, sondern wir erinnern uns daran,
dass sie halt viele Kampfflugzeuge aus allen Warschauer Paktstaaten,
was da an Suess noch übrig war, von Polen und Tschechien und weiß der Geierwehr,
wurde alles in Teilen und ganz in die Ukraine verschifft.
Und weitere 80 Kampfflugzeuge, dann überwiegend westlicher Bauart F-16.
Frankreich hat jetzt begonnen Mirage zu liefern und wahrscheinlich werden sie
irgendwann auch Grippen bekommen.
Aber 80 weitere Flugzeuge sind noch zugesagt und im Zulauf.
Und dann, wie gesagt, mittlerweile 33 Prozent produziert die Ukraine selbst mittlerweile.
Und ja, also zusammengefasst.
Kann man sagen, dass die Ukraine das Beste daraus macht und eigentlich dringend mehr Waffen bräuchte,
aber im Moment jetzt nicht ganz so schlecht dasteht und es eben teilweise Zugänge,
teilweise Verluste gegeben hat, so seit Kriegsbeginn.
Und ja, wenn die USA sich jetzt zurückziehen würden, wie gesagt,
40 Prozent der Waffen kamen im letzten Jahr aus den USA.
Unklar, inwieweit das anderweitig ausgeglichen werden könnte,
vermutlich nicht vollständig oder relativ sicher nicht vollständig.
Aber da ginge sicherlich noch mehr.
Also wenn die USA jetzt raus wären, würde wahrscheinlich Europa nochmal nachlegen
und nochmal, weiß ich nicht, 10, 20 Prozent.
Also wahrscheinlich vielleicht ein Drittel von dem oder die Hälfte von dem,
was die USA liefert, könnte wahrscheinlich Europa auch ausgleichen.
Ja, in dem Zusammenhang ist natürlich gerade die Diskussion um den Gripen ganz interessant.
Also das ist ja das Kampfflugzeug der Schweden.
Das ist schon länger im Gespräch, während die F-16 und auch die Mirage speziell
jetzt für den Bedarf an Ausrüstung mit Waffentechnik und Radartechnik einen
großen Sprung bedeutet für die Ukraine,
insbesondere die F-16, weil die F-16 so viel gebaut worden ist,
so universell, Das ist sozusagen das Universal-Kampfflugzeug,
wo du irgendwie alle möglichen Angriffs- und Verteidigungsraketensysteme dran befestigen kannst.
Die ist voll integriert in alle elektronischen Planungs- und Kampfabwicklungssysteme
und Automatiken. und von daher ist das halt einfach ein sehr wertvolles Gerät
und das muss irgendwie da sein.
Mit der Mirage gewinnen sie eine ähnliche Qualität und teilweise, glaube ich.
Aber ich weiß sie jetzt nicht so ganz genau. Auch nochmal irgendwie bessere Radarsysteme.
Die Gripen allerdings hat diesen griesigen Vorteil. Wir hatten auch schon mal
drüber gesprochen, aber ich bin da trotzdem sehr optimistisch,
dass das nochmal was wird.
Also erstmal ist es europäisch, das hängt also weniger von den USA ab.
Und vor allem ist die Gripen ja vor den Schweden explizit so gebaut worden,
dass sie so Low Maintenance hat.
Während du für eine F16 und wahrscheinlich auch für die Mirage einen ziemlichen
Aufwand treiben musst, was so den Support betrifft.
Also du brauchst halt irgendwie anspruchsvolle Landebahnen und musst die Dinger
irgendwie mit hohem Aufwand warten.
Und da ist also sehr viel Tamtam drumherum. ist die Gripen so ein bisschen so
das Schweizer Taschenmesser, was man immer mal so in der Hosentasche haben kann.
Die kann halt überall landen und die kann mit einem kleinen Team,
was irgendwie mit dem Range Rover aufläuft vor Ort, wenn die dann irgendwo auf
einer Wald- und Wiesenfläche gelandet ist, die irgendwie servicen und wieder in die Luft kriegen.
Und das ist natürlich etwas, was für die Ukraine.
Extrem wertvoll sein kann in der Zukunft, aber auch hier die Dinger müssen erstmal
produziert werden, die müssen geliefert werden, die müssen trainiert werden,
da muss Piloten für aufgebaut werden, muss es lernen etc., also das ist nichts,
was wahrscheinlich in 2025 einen großen Unterschied macht, dafür werden aber
die anderen Systeme jetzt in diesem Jahr anfangen, einen Unterschied zu machen.
Ja, also in Kosten, um das nochmal in Kosten zu formulieren,
also die Tschechen fliegen unter anderem Gripen und da sind die Zahlen bekannt
und das sind wohl um die 4.000,
zwischen 3.000 und 5.000 Dollar pro Flugstunde,
was sich so eine Gripen kostet.
So, bei der F-16 sind es zwischen 8.000 und 27.000 Dollar pro Flugstunde und
die F-35 kommt irgendwie auf über 30.000,
30.000 und 40.000 Dollar pro Flugstunde.
Also 33.000 Dollar, das heißt, Gripenkost ist zwar in der Anschaffung,
sind die auch nicht so viel billiger.
So, ich weiß nicht, eine F-35 liegt irgendwo, weiß nicht, um die 100 Millionen,
glaube ich und so eine Gripen 80, 90 Millionen irgendwo.
In der Gegend, also ist ein bisschen günstiger, aber der Unterschied ist eben dann Faktor 10 so,
während F-16s, gerade die älteren,
sind für deutlich weniger Geld zu haben.
Also eben auch dazu sagen, dass die modernen, dass die aktuellen Gripen deutlich
modernere und bessere und teurere Kampfflugzeuge sind als die F-16 jetzt oder
als der typische gebraucht F-16,
die die Ukraine derzeit so.
Okay, lass uns nicht so viel Zeit jetzt noch mit Waffensystemen vergeuden,
weil wir haben ja noch ein paar andere Themen, die wir hier ansprechen müssen.
Um vielleicht die ganze Battlefield-Situation und wie sind die einzelnen Parteien
jetzt aufgestellt nochmal abzuschließen, sollten wir vielleicht nochmal so ein
bisschen auf Russlands Probleme eingehen.
Also abgesehen davon, von dem, was wir jetzt schon so angesprochen haben,
dass sie also da extrem unter Feuer sind und dass sie halt, ja,
dass es ein bisschen unklar ist, wie lange ihr Material noch reicht.
Hauptproblem ist sicherlich die Personalsituation. Also wir haben ja sehr unterschiedliche
Auffassungen darüber, wie viel sie dann jetzt noch mobilisieren können oder
nicht. Aber es macht schon so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob sie große Schwierigkeiten
haben, diese Rekrutierung durchzuführen.
Erstmal ist es ja so, es wurde oft über eine Generalmobilisierung oder überhaupt
eine zweite Mobilisierungswelle nachgedacht.
Die erste war ja schon sehr, sehr, sehr unpopulär. Wir erinnern uns,
sie haben halt gesagt, so ja jetzt hier Krieg, Mobilisierung,
kommt mal alle ran, hat so eine Massenflucht aus dem Land geführt.
Natürlich haben sie es dann auch erstmal geschafft Leute zu bringen,
aber das hat einfach die Gesellschaft da extrem in Wallung gebracht.
So sehr, dass Putin auch nach seiner gefekten Wiederwahl das Thema nicht aufgegriffen
hat, auch wenn da viele mit gerechnet haben.
Und generell kann man einfach festhalten, so an Sankt Petersburg und Moskau
traut er sich da einfach nicht heran.
Also der wird einfach diese Mobilisierung deshalb schon nicht machen.
Und deswegen machen sie es halt mit Geld. Und das hat ja bisher eigentlich auch
ganz gut funktioniert, ist bloß sauteuer.
Und mittlerweile sind wohl diese Sign-up-Rates deutlich nach unten gegangen.
Also sie bekommen jetzt nicht mehr so viele.
Es melden sich schon immer noch irgendwelche, weil die Gelder,
die paar tausend Dollar, die da halt versprochen werden, sind halt für Russen
irgendwie enorme Summen.
Und irgendwie denken die halt nicht groß drüber nach, dass ihre Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit,
wenn sie an die Front geschickt werden, nur so vielleicht bei 1 zu 50 liegt. Wenn überhaupt.
Ja, also ich habe gehört, dass teilweise, aber in einigen Gegenden die Raten,
sozusagen Sign-up-Bonus, so auf umgerechnet 40.000 Dollar angestiegen ist,
aber dass sie eben gerade hochgehen müssen, weil sie nicht mehr genug Leute
finden und sie jetzt allgemein das Problem kommen, dass halt die Zahl der Leute,
die bereit sind, für Geld dieses Risiko einzugehen,
deutlich am Abnehmen ist.
Und irgendwann, klar, wenn du höher gehst,
aber die andere Sache ist, was ja auch klar ist, dass wir das letzte Mal schon gesagt haben,
dass Russland langsam das Geld ausgeht, dass sie halt sich diese hohen Personalkosten
nicht mehr leisten können.
Genau, das ist nämlich das Ding. Ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht ganz so sicher,
inwiefern wir das in der letzten Sendung schon mal angesprochen haben,
aber man kann das auf jeden Fall nochmal zusammenfassen.
Was passiert jetzt gerade also Russland braucht Personal und zwar brauchen sie
Personal sowohl in der Militärproduktion die sie extrem hoch fahren,
als auch im Battlefield das heißt sie loben jetzt extrem hohe Summen aus,
müssen also da schon mal sehr viel Geld in die Hand nehmen, sehr sehr sehr viel
Geld in die Hand nehmen und,
Das führt natürlich dann dazu, dass all die Leute, die sich für das Militär
entscheiden, und wir reden ja hier von Hunderttausenden,
dass die natürlich dann in der Wirtschaft fehlen, weil die Leute sich sagen
so, was soll ich jetzt hier in der Fabrik arbeiten, wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwie
beim Militär auch gleich mit so einem dicken Bonus starte und jeden Monat,
den ich da bin, so und so viel Geld bekomme, auch wenn sie dann nach zwei Monaten tot sind.
Machen sie das ja dann erstmal.
Mit anderen Worten, die Wirtschaft muss halt gegenhalten und auch die Militärproduktion
muss halt mithalten mit diesen Löhnen, damit die Leute dort halt überhaupt noch arbeiten.
Und das führt eben dazu, dass die Inflation extrem durch diese Nachfrage nach oben getrieben wird.
Die Leute kriegen halt immer mehr Geld und auf der anderen Seite führt es aber
nicht dazu, dass die Wirtschaft angekurbelt wird, weil eigentlich der Wirtschaft
fehlen halt wichtige Leute.
Auf der einen Seite fliehen viele Leute, auf der anderen Seite gehen die Leute
in die Militärproduktion und die Militärproduktion ist halt nichts,
was die Wirtschaft nach vorne bringt.
Da wird zwar jetzt viel Geld vernichtet, aber dieses Geld wird im Wesentlichen gedruckt,
die Preise schießen nach oben und es geht halt mit der Wirtschaft selber nicht
voran und das hat halt jetzt zu so einem Zustand geführt, den man so als Stagflation bezeichnet,
dass man also sowohl eine Inflation hat, die ja normalerweise Ausdruck einer
hochdrehenden hyperaktiven Wirtschaft ist.
Deswegen macht man dann die Zinsen höher mit, hey Leute, geht mal ein bisschen
langsam an die Sache ran, nimmt man nicht so viel Kredite auf,
ihr übernimmt euch und die Preise gehen jetzt irgendwie nach oben.
Das ist ja das normale Regelwerk. Immer wenn wir hören, Zentralbank geht mit den Zinsen hoch.
Dann ist es um irgendwie die Wirtschaftsaktivität ein bisschen runter zu drücken,
weil Kredite halt teuer werden, dann nehmen die Firmen nicht mehr so viel Kredite
auf und dadurch wird sozusagen so eine hyperaktive Wirtschaft ein bisschen in Griff gehalten.
Aber hier ist das Gegenteil der Fall. Es gibt eigentlich immer weniger wirtschaftliche
Aktivität, weil alles ins Militär geht. Trotzdem steigen die Preise und die Löhne.
Und das ist das, was man so Stagflation nennt. Das ist also so eine Stagnation und Inflation in einem.
Und das ist ein sehr schwieriger Zustand. Und der wird noch sehr viel problematischer,
wenn dieser Krieg irgendwann mal vorbei ist und du sozusagen feststellst,
oh 60 Prozent unserer Wirtschaftsaktivität war jetzt irgendwie für den Krieg,
jetzt fällt der Krieg weg,
dann dauert es teilweise Jahre, bis so eine Wirtschaft sich wieder normalisiert, wenn überhaupt.
Und das ist halt ein Problem. Weiteres Problem ist, dass eben Russland,
wie wir ja schon angedeutet haben,
Schwierigkeiten hat, seine Haupteinnahmequelle zu bedienen, dadurch,
dass die Ukraine halt jetzt die Ölproduktion zerstört und dass auch die USA,
jetzt letzte Entscheidung von Biden,
die Sanktionen nochmal extrem gesteigert hat.
Also auf den letzten Metern hat ja dann Biden tatsächlich nochmal die Sanktionen verschärft.
War es vorher noch möglich für Russland mit dieser Shadowfleet,
also nicht mit russischen Tankern, sondern eben mit gemieteten Tankern auf aller
Welt in irgendeiner Form Indien und China und so weiter zu bedienen und wer noch bereit war,
ihnen Öl abzunehmen, wahrscheinlich Brasilien und so,
sind jetzt eben auch diese ganzen Shadowfleet-Tanker mit Sanktionen belegt worden.
Also sie dürfen da nicht versichert werden und dürfen helfen nicht anlaufen
und die stehen jetzt irgendwo alle mitten auf hoher See rum und wissen nicht
so richtig, was sie machen sollen und laden auch kein neues Öl ein.
Also das ist für die auf jeden Fall auch ein Problem.
Sprich, Russland hat auch ein Problem mit den Einnahmen.
Und dazu ist bekannt geworden, dass Putin wohl auch die ganzen Privatbanken
gezwungen hat, dem Militärbereich auch nochmal Kredite zu geben,
so nach dem Motto, ihr müsst jetzt hier auch mal was machen,
ohne dass das irgendwie offiziell verkündet wurde, das kam jetzt nur so raus.
Und das sind natürlich auch Kredite, die diese Privatbanken nie wiederbekommen.
Mit anderen Worten, die machen dann halt auch noch Verluste.
Und das ist so die Gesamtsituation.
Dazu kommt, dass diese ganzen Rüstungsunternehmen trotz dieser hohen Auftragslage,
aber wegen der hohen Gewinne und sonstigen Materialkosten auch,
überhaupt gar keinen Gewinn machen und nahezu bankrott sind.
Also da ist sozusagen auch nichts.
Und das ist auf jeden Fall eines der größten Probleme, die Russland hat.
Und diese Mangelverfügbarkeit von Personal hat ja dann auch dazu geführt,
dass sie dann zu Nordkorea gegangen sind und gesagt haben, könnt ihr nicht mal
ein paar Leute schicken.
Es ging ja los erstmal mit Artillerielieferungen.
Damit fing das ja an, dass Nordkorea angefangen hat, Munition zu liefern in
größerem Umfang, schon seit längerem.
Und ja, dann wurden 10.000 Soldaten schickt.
Ja, das weiß man nicht so genau.
Nach, ja, aber man geht davon aus, in der Größenordnung von 10.000.
Die dann auch gleich an der Front eingesetzt wurden, offenbar ohne allzu viel
gebrieft worden zu sein, wie das denn an der Front so zugeht.
Und dann eben in klassischer Formation bei Tag in voller Mannschaft losgelaufen
sind über offene Felder.
Und das ging halt nicht gut.
Die haben dann massive Verluste erlitten und wurden jetzt wohl von der Front
in Kursk abgezogen erst mal wieder.
Und jetzt ist unklar, warum.
Man geht aber davon aus, dass sie erstmal jetzt gucken,
sich reorganisieren müssen und vielleicht aus den Erfahrungen lernen und dann
wieder an die Front zurückkommen.
Nichts Genaues weiß man nicht, aber im Moment sind sie wohl aktuell nicht an der Front.
Also es gab jetzt schon wieder jüngste Berichte, dass sie jetzt schon wieder
zum Einsatz gekommen sind nach dieser kurzen Pause.
Aber einen großen Unterschied haben sie bisher nicht gemacht und die Verluste waren wohl enorm.
Also das ist nichts, was Russland groß vorangebracht hat.
Front ist übrigens auch relativ, sie sind ja in Kurs zum Einsatz gekommen.
Also sie haben die Nordkoreaner nicht in die Ukraine geschickt,
sondern sie haben sie irgendwie in Russland zum Einsatz gebracht.
Das war auch ein ziemlich brutales Regime, wie man sich vorstellen kann.
Ich meine, man kann sich vorstellen, dass diese Nordkoreaner, die halt irgendwie...
Wahrscheinlich die meisten einfach die russische Sprache, auch nicht beherrschen
und es kaum Übersetzer gibt.
Die waren da einfach komplett lost und es ist ja dann berichtet worden,
dass die Russen auch so den Auftrag hatten, so verletzte Nordkoreaner dann auch
einfach gleich zu erschießen, um einfach zu verhindern, dass die in irgendeiner
Form gefangen genommen werden.
Das ist dann natürlich trotzdem passiert und die, die halt dann festgenommen
wurden, Die berichteten dann auch natürlich,
dass sie erstmal überhaupt nicht wussten, wo sie hinkommen und dass irgendwie
alles nach Manöver aussah und auf einmal fanden sie sich halt im Krieg wieder
und wussten halt nicht, wo oben und unten ist.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist es natürlich eine Ungeheuerlichkeit,
dass jetzt nordkoreanische Truppen ein europäisches Land angreifen.
Ja, dass das in sich genommen ist,
ja, wenn man spekuliert, befinden wir uns vielleicht schon im dritten Weltkrieg
und haben es noch nicht gemerkt.
Ich meine, der Erste Weltkrieg wurde auch nicht Erster Weltkrieg genannt,
während er wurde sogar nicht Erster Weltkrieg genannt,
bevor der Zweite Weltkrieg zu Ende war. Ja, das können wir erzählen.
Ist noch eine neue Geschichte.
Ich würde sagen, ja, das ist definitiv ein Weltkrieg.
Er ist vielleicht insofern jetzt kein Weltkrieg auf dem Level der anderen Weltkriege,
weil die Zahl der Nationen, die jetzt unmittelbar beteiligt ist,
noch nicht so angeschwollen ist.
Aber indirekt gibt es natürlich schon diverse Player. Iran spielt eine Rolle.
Und natürlich der gesamte Westen auch.
Also ich meine in dem Moment, man kann jetzt natürlich darüber diskutieren,
sind wir jetzt Kriegsbeteiligte, weil wir irgendwie Waffen liefern und so weiter,
aber das bedroht uns ja auch und insofern, klar ist das ein Weltkrieg,
ob es jetzt der dritte oder der 2.5.
Ist, ist ehrlich gesagt ziemlich Wumpe,
die Problematik existiert und die Tatsache, dass halt ja sogar Nordkorea eingreift
als absoluter Schurkenstaat sollte halt sehr viel mehr auf die Barrikaden bringen,
aber die Politik ignoriert das natürlich ganz wunderbar weiterhin,
und ja gut, zur politischen Einschätzung, kommen wir sicherlich nochmal gleich.
Aber das ist jetzt der Grad an Beteiligung, den Nordkorea halt hier derzeit
betreibt und es wird auch gemunkelt, dass da noch mehr Soldaten folgen sollen.
Ich würde jetzt gerne nochmal einen Nebenkriegsschauplatz im wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes aufmachen und sagen,
Nach Syrien blicken, weil da ist ja was sehr Unerwartetes passiert.
Ihr werdet es alle irgendwie mitbekommen haben, aber ich dachte,
es ist nochmal ganz gut, so ein bisschen die Situation zusammenzufassen,
wie sie sich da jetzt darstellt und welche Auswirkungen das auch auf diesen
Konflikt haben kann oder bereits hat.
Was ist passiert.
Also wir hatten ja in Syrien 2011 den großen Aufstand und aus diesen Protesten,
die sich im Wesentlichen um Wasserverteilung und so weiter drehten,
ist ja dann schnell so ein Anti-Assad-Aufstand geworden und wir haben dann alle gesehen,
wie Assad halt mit Hilfe der Russen drauf reagiert hat.
Nämlich mit Tod und Zerstörung, was ja dann zu sehr hohlen Flüchtlingszahlen geführt hat.
Millionen von Syrern haben das Land verlassen und bis vor kurzem noch sah es eben so aus,
als Orsad seine Macht eigentlich wieder beisammen hat und nichts so richtig dort vorankommt.
Wie man sich doch irren kann.
Das Ganze kam aber im Prinzip durch die Angriffe der Hamas auf Israel jetzt
in Wallung, auch wenn sich das nicht sofort abgezeichnet hat.
Aber dadurch, dass halt Israel jetzt erstmal die Hamas so massiv bekämpft hat im Gazastreifen.
Dann aber auch noch die Traute hatte, sich auch noch mit der Hisbollah anzulegen
und dort ja auch der Hisbollah massiven Schaden zugefügt hat.
Also in diesem Krieg, da haben wir jetzt nicht so viel drüber geredet,
aber es ist ja Israel gelungen, im Prinzip die komplette Führungsriege der Hezbollah zu töten,
also bis hin zum Chef Nasrallah, aber eben auch darunter ein,
zwei Ebenen, da gab es ja diese...
Was ja sehr viel Aufsehen erzielt hat,
sind diese Angriffe mit den fernexplodierenden Pagern und fernexplodierenden
Walkie Talkies und später dann eben auch die Luftschläge mit denen unter anderem
eben Nasrallah und weitere Führungsebenen und dann eben auch extrem viele Waffenstandorte
der Hilfsboller zerstört wurden.
Und dieses Boller war ja nun schon immer Buddy mit Assad und schon immer Buddy mit Iran.
Und in dieses Machtvakuum ist dann eine Rebellenoffensive reingegrätscht.
Achso, es gab ja auch noch eine Waffenauseinandersetzung zwischen Israel und Iran.
Iran hat ja dann Israel angegriffen, dann gab es den ersten Bombenangriff,
dann wurde darauf geantwortet, dann gab es nochmal einen Bombenangriff,
der auch ein bisschen mehr Schaden noch erzeugt hat als der erste.
Nichts, was jetzt Israel in große Nöte gebracht hat, aber Israel ist ja immer
sehr darauf bedacht, bei keinem Angriff in irgendeiner Form Schaden zu erleiden.
Da sah es dann halt schon anders aus und es war auch so ein bisschen underreported,
aber der Luftschlag, den die Israelis auf Iran gemacht haben,
der war auch signifikant.
Also sie haben dort vor allem die Luftabwehr der Iraner wohl nachhaltig zerstört bekommen.
Genaue Zahlen gibt es da nicht, aber das lief nicht gut für den Iran.
So und das war jetzt die Situation.
Hamas, gut, spielt jetzt für Syrien keine unmittelbare Rolle,
aber war natürlich stark dezimiert.
Dann Hezbollah, spielt für Syria eine extrem hohe Rolle,
war quasi enthauptet worden und der Iran selbst auf einmal auch in großen Nöten
jetzt auch seine ganze Militärproduktion erstmal auf die eigene Sicherheit zu fokussieren.
Und dann gab es halt eine Rebellen-Offensive, die startete im Dezember oder
was im November, ich weiß nicht,
noch im November glaube ich und die ging vom Norden aus, aus einem Gebiet in der Nähe der Türkei,
was auch so ein bisschen Protektion der Türkei mit genoss.
Und die Gruppe, die dort aktiv war, hieß HTS.
Und die sind dann nach Süden vorgestoßen und trafen zunächst einmal in Köln.
Das ist die Stadt in Aleppo. Auf bemerkenswert wenig Widerstand.
Also es gab einen Vorstoß und nach ein, zwei Tagen war die Stadt genommen.
Und die ganzen syrischen Truppen haben sich gar nicht groß gewehrt,
sondern sind im Wesentlichen geflohen. Und dann setzte das Ganze eine Kettenreaktion in Gang.
Die Rebellen sind dann mit Windeseile weiter nach Süden, die Kette von Städten
abklappernd nach Süden fortgefahren,
haben dann Homs eingenommen und dann war eigentlich auch schon relativ klar, das geht nicht gut aus.
Und dann gab es noch weitere verbündete Truppen, die dann im Süden die Kämpfe
aufgenommen haben und nach, wie lange war es jetzt, nach ein, zwei Wochen,
nach zwei Wochen war es dann einfach mal vorbei mit Assad.
Assad ist dann geflohen und mittlerweile ist Syrien weitgehend unter der Kontrolle der HTS.
Und die Russen, die haben noch kurz versucht, da irgendwas zu machen,
haben mit ihren Flugzeugen Angriffe geflogen gegen die HTS,
auch versucht ein paar Brücken noch zu bombardieren.
Aber dadurch, dass die Assatsche Armee eigentlich sofort in Auflösung war,
haben die Russen dann auch gesehen, dass sie sozusagen überhaupt gar keine Allianzen
mehr haben und haben sich dann einfach zurückgezogen.
Und der Sieg der Rebellen war da, zur großen Überraschung.
Und heute auf morgen war Syrien nicht mehr in der Hand von Assad,
dessen Familie dieses Land 50 Jahre lang komplett unterjucht hat.
Und ja, die neue Situation ist bemerkenswert, weil jetzt,
was man noch dazu sagen muss, Israel hat natürlich dann die Gelegenheit auch
genutzt und dieses Machtvakuum sofort für sich in Vorteil gezogen, indem sie a,
weitere Gebiete in den Golanhöhen besetzt haben, unter anderem den höchsten
Berg der Region, wo sie bisher immer nur in der Nähe waren.
Aber jetzt kontrollieren sie sozusagen die syrische Seite davon,
neben dem Libanon und haben halt so ihr Einflussgebiet nochmal so um 10,
20 Kilometer ausgebreitet, also auf längerer Strecke.
Da kann man jetzt geteilter Meinung darüber sein, wie rechtmäßig das ist,
aber das interessiert glaube ich die Israelis an der Stelle überhaupt nicht.
Und sie haben eine Vielzahl von Bombenangriffen geflogen und einen Großteil
der syrischen Waffensysteme, modernen Waffensysteme,
also Flugzeuge und Luftabwehr zerstört quasi.
Nicht nur, dass auch die komplette Navy ist bei draufgegangen.
Also man kann davon ausgehen, dass Israel innerhalb weniger Tage 80,
90 Prozent der gesamten syrischen Armee zerstört hat.
Oder mit anderen Worten, es gibt keine Luftabwehr mehr in Syrien.
Es gibt vermutlich kein großes Bedrohungspotenzial mehr.
Auch diese Chemiewaffenproduktion, die es in Syrien gab, dürfte mittlerweile
aufgelöst worden, wenn nicht sogar teilweise zerstört worden sein.
Das weiß ich jetzt im Einzelnen nicht.
Und alles, was halt an Booten und Navy da war, ist alles komplett zerstört worden.
Ja, sie haben auch Assads Drogenlabore ausgehoben. Ich weiß nicht,
ob du das mitgekriegt hast.
Ja, das haben dann also nicht die Israelis gemacht, sondern das haben die Syrer selber gemacht.
Ja, ja, ja. Und ich meine, was ich mich gefragt hatte, als das da auf einmal
losging, die ganzen Kürzel, die da plötzlich zu hören waren,
wer da eigentlich gegen wen gerade kämpft.
Und so, also gerade in Rebellenorganisationen, die ja auch untereinander teilweise
dann noch gekämpft haben, so fand ich erstmal völlig verwirrend.
Und ich habe mich gefragt, wer zum Teufel ist diese HTS?
So, ich sage mal, was hat man davon zu halten?
Weil es hieß natürlich sehr schnell, ja eigentlich ist das eher so eine jihadistische
Organisation und der Führer war mal bei Al-Qaida und haben sich aber irgendwie
von Al-Qaida dann abgespalten.
Und ja, generell scheint es wohl so zu sein, ja, sind irgendwie erzkonservative
Islamisten, aber relativ gemäßigt so.
Und tatsächlich auch laut Untersuchungen von NGOs,
die so regelmäßig Rankings machen, sind sie tatsächlich die Terrororganisation,
die die wenigsten Zivilisten umgebracht hatten in Syrien im Krieg.
Terrororganisation mit menschlichen Antlitz.
Ja genau, also sie haben nur irgendwie wohl 560 Zivilisten umgebracht laut dieser
Statistik und sie schienen auch aber tatsächlich dann ja Ordnung,
sich als tatsächlich Ordnungsmacht etabliert zu haben.
Im Gegensatz zu einigen anderen Rebellengruppen, die dann von Süden kamen,
die erstmal auf Plünderungen aus waren,
die dann rein sind in die Stadt und irgendwie sich alles unter den Nagel gerissen
haben, was nicht nid- und nagelfest war, hat dann wohl die HTS dann unter anderem
diese Plünderungen unterbunden.
Also HTS heißt Hayat Tahrir Asch Ascham,
wir kennen es alle, Komitee zur Befreiung der Levante, Levante ist ja der Begriff
für diesen ganzen mittelmeernahen Bereich Syriens.
Vielleicht die Abkürzung nochmal vervollständigen, es gibt derzeit vier Player,
die jetzt in Syrien eine Rolle spielen.
Neben HTS, die den Großteil des Landes, Damaskus, Homs, die wichtigen Städte
Aleppo und auch den alevitischen Teil am Mittelmeer kontrollieren,
gibt es dann noch die, das ist mit diesen Abkürzungen so eine Sache, die SNA,
also die Syrian National Army.
Das ist eine wiederum noch mehr von der Türkei geförderte Gruppe,
die derzeit noch extrem im Konflikt ist und auch noch Kämpfe durchführt gegen
die SDF, das ist die syrische demokratische Fraktion, wenn ich es richtig erinnere.
Aber das ist quasi die im Wesentlichen kurdisch geführte Widerstandsgruppe,
die so jenseits des Euphratflusses, der dann Syrien nochmal in zwei Teile teilt,
Richtung Kurdistan die Gebiete unter Kontrolle hat.
Und dann gab es halt die SAA, also die syrische Armee von Assad,
die gibt es halt jetzt nicht mehr. Das heißt, du hast jetzt im Wesentlichen drei Gruppen.
HTS stellt jetzt auch den Präsidenten, dieser Al-Jolani, wie er genannt wurde,
seinen richtigen Namen erinnere ich jetzt gerade nicht, hat sich ja jetzt wieder
umbenannt, hat seinen Kampfnamen abgelegt sozusagen.
Im Norden hast du noch die SNA, die halt mit der Türkei versucht irgendwie diese
PKK nahen Kurden aus dem Grenzbereich der Türkei zu verdrängen und dann eben die SDF,
die halt kurdisch sind, aber bei den Kurden gibt es ja nicht so eine einheitliche
Fraktion, sondern da gibt es ja sozusagen die Kurden, die sehr viel mehr dem
eigentlichen Kurdistan zuzurechnen sind.
Und dieser PKK-Teil der Kurden, der ist nochmal anders drauf und auch eher problematisch.
Naja, auf jeden Fall ist Syrien jetzt unter neuer Regierung.
Die HTS benimmt sich bisher sehr gemäßigt und das Ganze lässt einen ein wenig hoffen,
dass die Situation sich in Syrien zumindest nicht weiter verschlechtert,
sondern im Idealfall auch noch stabilisiert.
Und wenn es richtig gut läuft, könnte dabei ein okayes Land bei rauskommen,
was vielen geflüchteten Syriern vielleicht auch wieder eine neue Heimat bieten
kann, was sich wirtschaftlich neu entwickeln kann,
aber was vor allem halt keinerlei Gefahr mehr für Israel darstellt.
Insofern ist Israel, glaube ich, der große Gewinner dieses gesamten Konflikts
bei allem, was man Israel jetzt vorwerfen kann bei ihren Vorgängen.
Aber der Nahe Osten ist weniger bedrohlich geworden.
Und das hat natürlich auch viel damit zu tun, dass der Iran eigentlich der große Verlierer hier ist.
Weil hatte der Iran bis vor wenigen Monaten im Prinzip über seine schiitischen
Mitstreiter im Süden Iraks und dann eben den Assad-Truppen einen Landweg bis
in den Libanon und bis zur Hisbollah ist dieser Landweg jetzt komplett abgeschnitten.
Und durch die Zerstörung der ganzen Luftabwehr und natürlich auch durch die
Änderung der Regierung ist jetzt eben auch der Luftweg komplett geöffnet worden.
Das heißt, während der Iran vorher eine Bedrohung für Israel war,
ist jetzt Israel im Wesentlichen eine Bedrohung für den Iran.
Weil dadurch, dass der syrische Luftspace sich durch Syrien zumindest nicht
mehr verteidigen lässt.
Hat Israel im Prinzip jetzt ein riesiges Ausrittgebiet und kann theoretisch
mit den F-35-Kampfflugzeugen und Tankflugzeugen,
die dann eben die Reichweite dieser F-35-Kampfflugzeuge signifikant erweitern,
im Prinzip jedes Ziel im Iran angreifen.
Der Iran ist jetzt sozusagen auf einmal in the crosshairs und ich wäre nicht
sonderlich überrascht, wenn wir in der Hinsicht auch nochmal mehr Aktivität sehen.
Ich glaube, dass Israel jetzt gerade erstmal dabei ist, kräftig die Wunden zu
lecken und die Reserven aufzustocken, aber der Iran hat ein Problem.
Und wer natürlich auch noch ein riesiges Problem hat, ist Russland.
Denn Russland war ja nicht nur ein Unterstützer Assads, sondern sie hatten ja
dort zwei militärische Stützpunkte.
Also sie hatten viele militärische Stützpunkte, aber vor allem zwei wesentliche
militärische Stützpunkte, die sehr, sehr, sehr wichtig waren für Russland,
nämlich einen Hafen und einen Flughafen.
Und beides müssen sie jetzt aufgeben. Ich glaube, der Flughafen ist schon übergeben worden.
Der Hafen wird jetzt gerade so als letztes noch gecleared.
Also da werden so die letzten Container verladen.
Und die HTS hat halt gesagt, geht in Frieden, aber geht.
Um es mal salopp zu formulieren. Also sie sind da relativ klug vorgegangen.
Sie haben gar nicht erst groß versucht, den Russen jetzt irgendwie noch einen
Denkzettel zu verpassen und dann noch irgendein Konflikt sich einzutreten und
sinnlos irgendwie Leute zu töten.
Sondern wir haben denen einfach klar gemacht, so Leute, ihr habt hier nichts mehr zu suchen.
Ja, wir lassen euch jetzt mal in Frieden.
Aber wenn ihr irgendwie aufmuckt, ihr seid jetzt über den Artillerie-Range und
wir machen euch einfach platt.
Und wenn ihr irgendwie euren Scheiß jetzt noch irgendwie eingepackt bekommt,
ist gut, nehmt weg so, aber geht in Frieden.
Und das war es dann halt mit der russischen Militärpräsenz im Mittelmeer auf syrischem Gebiet.
Und das ist natürlich für Russland ein riesiges Problem,
weil diese Standorte, dieser Hafen und auch der Flughafen extrem wichtige Logistik-Hubs
waren für die russischen Aktivitäten in Afrika.
Haben wir ja auch schon mal angesprochen, Russland bekämpft die westliche Welt überall.
Und das tun sie halt nicht nur in der Ukraine,
sondern das tun sie unter anderem
auch im Sudan, das tun sie in allen afrikanischen Staaten der Sahelzone.
Mali, Niger, oh Gott, kriege ich das jetzt alle aufgezählt.
Also dieser ganze Burkina Faso, überall gab es in den letzten zwei,
drei Jahren Militärputsche, die von den Russen und den Wagner-Truppen vor allem
gedeckt wurden und der Einfluss Frankreichs wurde halt extrem,
reduziert, was für die Franzosen ja auch nochmal ein Problem ist,
aber diese ganze logistische Unterstützung dieser Truppen lief halt alles über Syrien.
Und der einzige Standort, den die Russen jetzt im Mittelmeerraum überhaupt noch
haben, ist so ein relativ kleiner.
Hafenoption im östlichen Teil Libyens, wo sie mit einem dieser Warlords zusammenarbeiten,
Haftar oder wie der heißt.
Also es gibt da eine libysche Hauptstadt im Westen und dann gibt es halt quasi
auf der ägyptischen Seite Libyens gibt es halt nochmal einen anderen Warlord.
Das ist derzeit auch alles in einem sehr schlechten Zustand da in Libyen und
da halt also Russland noch ein bisschen Einfluss.
Aber Syrien war ihr Goldstück und das ist jetzt weg und das ist jetzt die Gesamtsituation.
Das heißt durch die Schwächung.
Russlands nicht nur deswegen, aber eben auch wegen des Konflikts mit der Hezbollah
und dem Iran, haben im Prinzip Iran und Russland ihren wichtigsten Kampfplatz verloren.
Und das ist natürlich für die Ambitionen, für die imperialen Ambitionen,
die Russland hat, ein großes Problem.
Ja, und es zeigt aber auch, dass wenn man den Russen dann nur genug Widerstand entgegensetzt,
dass sie sich halt auch zurückziehen, dass man Russen eben auch vertreiben kann.
Und das finde ich ist auch nochmal so ein wichtiger Punkt und zeigt halt ja,
sagen die, auch die Schwäche Russlands und dass sie da nicht in der Lage waren, gegenzuhalten.
Und es zeigt eben auch, aber selbst wenn du Diktator bist, läuft halt nicht
alles so, wie du das gerne hättest.
Manche Dinge sind einfach praktisch unmöglich. Und ja,
dann sind wir schon an dem Punkt jetzt, wo wir langsam den Elefanten im Raum lassen.
Nochmal den Porzellan, den Elefanten im Porzellan laden.
Ja, müssen wir jetzt leider. Also USA, ganz klar, ist natürlich jetzt das Thema
und damit kommen wir auch wieder ein bisschen auf den Krieg in der Ukraine zurück.
Wir haben also jetzt diesen Machtwechsel, Transition of Power hat stattgefunden,
Biden hat, das habe ich schon erwähnt, er hat nochmal auf den letzten Metern
alles an Kohle rausgehauen, was irgendwie machbar war, maximale Waffenlieferungen geliefert,
ein bisschen Geld noch ein bisschen übrig gelassen, damit Trump stillschweigend
auch noch ein bisschen was ausgeben kann, ohne dann nochmal den Kongresskirre
machen zu müssen, ob er das nutzen wird, wird man dann sehen,
aber auch dann eben diese verschärften Sanktionen.
Die schon dazu geführt haben, dass also Indien und China sich ein bisschen zurückgenommen
haben und jetzt erstmal kein Öl mehr aus Russland kaufen werden.
Zumindest gibt es jetzt keine Bestellung mehr, glaube ich, ab März.
Und ja, jetzt ist natürlich viel darüber diskutiert worden, welche Haltung die
Trump-Administration jetzt einnehmen wird gegenüber Ukraine.
Die letzten Jahre waren ja gefüllt damit, dass die ganzen Republikaner sehr
prorussisch argumentiert haben,
die ganze rechte Medienlandschaft hat halt irgendwie derbe ausgeteilt gegen
Zelensky und Putin war immer ganz toll und überhaupt.
Und die erste Präsidentschaft von Trump war ja auch davon geprägt,
dass er ihn da irgendwie angehimmelt hat und ihn so ein bisschen als Strongman wahrgenommen hat.
Bloß ich glaube, diese Sichtweise hat sich jetzt doch extrem geändert,
weil nach drei Jahren Krieg kann Russland halt irgendwie vorweisen,
irgendwie 50 Kilometer irgendwo vorangekommen zu sein, indem sie eine Million
Menschenleute umgebracht haben auf beiden Seiten.
Und das ist natürlich jetzt irgendwie keine Situation, wo man sagen würde,
Putin ist aber jetzt hier wirklich der Geilste.
Dazu kommt, dass die Strategie von der Ukraine, die politische Strategie wohl
eher lautet, die USA daran zu erinnern, wie viel Geld man mit der Ukraine verdienen
kann. Und das ist natürlich etwas, was Trump super interessiert.
Also dass man jetzt irgendwie hier Bodenschätze etc.
Davon profitieren kann. Da gibt es gerade so die Debatte um Rare Earth,
Lithiumvorkommen, alles mögliche.
Nur das ist halt alles in diesem von Russland derzeit besetzten Gebieten und
da müsste man natürlich ein bisschen was machen, wenn man da ran will.
Ja, das Problem oder erstmal ist vieles so gekommen,
wie wir in der letzten Sendung auch gesagt haben.
Also der, sagen wir Trumps Plan oder das, was jetzt dieser Kellogg,
der glaube ich Kellogg heißt ja, der Gesandte von Trump, der da jetzt Friedensplan ausarbeiten soll.
Und tatsächlich haben die,
ja, das,
was sie in Project 25 niedergeschrieben hatten, versuchen sie jetzt auch erstmal so umzusetzen.
Gut, Trump hat ja im Wahlkampf noch damit geprahlt, ja er wird sagen, den Krieg am Tag seiner,
Amtsübernahme in einem Tag beenden. Das ist natürlich nicht passiert.
Da gibt es offiziell drei Monate, so ist der Zeitplan, also innerhalb von drei
Monaten irgendwie was auszuhandeln.
Ja, also Der Plan war grundsätzlich der, zu sagen, okay,
er zwingt beide Parteien zum Frieden, indem er dann mit Zuckerbrot und Peitsche beide Seiten sagt,
entweder ihr hört jetzt auf zu kämpfen und stimmt jetzt einem Waffenstillstand zu.
Oder wenn Russland nicht mitzieht,
dann will er die Ukraine massiv unterstützen mit allem, was er hat.
Und wenn die Ukraine nicht mitzieht, will er der Ukraine den Waffen- und Geldhahn abdrehen.
Und das war das, was beschrieben war, so an Strategie oder Idee,
die sie versuchen jetzt auch grundsätzlich irgendwie umzusetzen.
Die anfänglichen Reaktionen von Russland waren sehr interessant,
fand ich, so auf Trump und auf Trumps Sieg.
Also sie waren ja eigentlich anfänglich, also bevor er wirklich gewählt wurde
oder so, hatte man das Gefühl,
sie wollen lieber Trump als Harris.
So, dass sie gewisse Hoffnungen mit Trump einfach verbunden haben,
dass er eben der Ukraine die Waffenhilfe abdrehen wird, was im Wahlkampf auch den Anschein machte.
Aber ich kann erst mal feststellen, er hat halt erst mal jetzt nichts Konkretes gemacht.
Also hat weder jetzt der Ukraine den Hahn abgedreht, noch hat er jetzt bisher
irgendwie Waffenlieferungen ausgeweitet.
Die Ukraine, wie wir schon erwähnt haben,
haben dieses ganze Chaos genutzt, um ein bisschen freier agieren zu können und
eben auch weniger Zurückhaltung zu zeigen.
Und ja, aus Trumps Sicht natürlich kommt ihm das bisher ganz, ganz gut hin.
Scheint ihm das ganz gut gelegen zu kommen, wenn die Ukraine jetzt für Verhandlungen
eher besser dasteht als schlechter.
So, das ist die eine Sache.
Das Problem jetzt ist mit dem, was Trump sonst so von sich gegeben hat an Äußerungen,
wie er sonst so der Welt gegenüber aufgetreten ist.
Also angefangen mit dem Handelskrieg mit Kanada und Mexiko und der Idee jetzt
Grönland zu kaufen und dann neuerdings jetzt.
Nachdem die alle drei Nein gesagt haben, hat er sich jetzt überlegt den Gazastreifen
irgendwie Besen rein von Israel übernehmen zu wollen.
Also ohne Leute und ja, also Trump hat halt unglaublich viel,
unglaublich idiotisch erscheinende Dinge getan, die vermutlich nicht nur idiotisch
erscheinen, sondern auch idiotisch sind.
Ich meine, ich habe versucht, das irgendwie mal zu steelmannen, so nach dem Motto, okay,
das ist jetzt Trumpsche Verhandlungstaktik, die Art of Deal,
1000 Prozent fordern und dann am Ende bei 150 Prozent rauskommen.
Aber Politik und die Welt ist einfach viel, viel komplizierter als Business jetzt.
Und was man dann auch gesehen hat, war,
dass er dann erstmal jetzt, sagen wir mal, den Handelskrieg mit Mexiko und Kanada um 30 Tage,
jetzt erstmal für 30 Tage ausgesetzt hat, also dort quasi zurückgerudert ist.
Und scheinbar auch jetzt so ein bisschen das Interesse an Grönland verloren hat.
Also es ist jedenfalls kein großes Thema mehr.
Und die Kanadier sind halt jetzt alle ziemlich pisst.
Und was jetzt mit so Europa, hat die Grönland-Nummer jetzt auch nicht gerade
für Begeisterung gesorgt. Aber die Kanadier.
Und bei Trump sind immer Grundsätze wichtig.
Am besten ignorieren, was er sagt und gucken, was er tut.
Das scheint wichtig zu sein. Aber es ist nicht so, dass das,
was er sagt, jetzt bedeutungslos wäre.
Sondern egal wie irrsinnig es ist, es zerstört halt Vertrauen.
Das ist das Problem im ersten Schritt.
Und im zweiten Schritt zerstört es Glaubwürdigkeit,
wenn er nämlich dann natürlich an die Grenzen des Machbaren stößt und man feststellt,
das, was er ankündigt oder androht, ist er nicht in der Lage umzusetzen.
Und das wird jetzt natürlich auch zu einem Riesenproblem für die ganzen Friedensbemühungen
oder für den Friedensplan,
weil natürlich dann Garantien nötig sind.
Oder nicht nur das, sondern im ersten Schritt überhaupt, damit jetzt die Russen
eine Ausweitung der Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine als glaubwürdige Drohung empfinden.
Müssen sie auch davon überzeugt sein, dass Trump das dann durchziehen wird.
Wenn er dann aber jetzt mittlerweile fünf Dinge angekündigt oder versucht oder angedroht hat,
von denen er keins durchgezogen hat, das ist einfach wie desaströse Kindererziehung.
Wenn Muttern irgendwie an der Kasse sagt, Kind, hör jetzt auf zu quengeln oder
wenn du das noch einmal machst, dann.
Und das Kind tritt dann trotzdem zu oder greift ins Regal.
Nein, nein, wenn du das jetzt noch einmal machst. Also Problem ist,
dass Trump, der durchaus ein gewisses Potenzial hatte, jetzt mit Mad-Man-Politik zu arbeiten.
Gewisse Durchbrüche zu erzielen, einfach seine Glaubwürdigkeit und sein politisches
Kapital und auch seine Abschreckungsfähigkeit,
dass er die jetzt Stück um Stück verliert.
Und außerdem innenpolitisch ist halt auch das Problem, dass er halt sich dort
eben aufführt wie ein Elefant im Porzellanladen und man sehen wird,
wie viel von seiner Gleichschaltungs- und Rache und weiß ich nicht,
was Politik gegenüber dem Staatsapparat und Staatsbeamten inwieweit er damit
jetzt durchkommen wird.
Weil auch dort stößt er jetzt auf erhebliche Probleme.
Und auch innerhalb der Republikaner natürlich die ganzen Senatoren und Abgeordneten
haben natürlich auch Heimatwahlkreise und so.
Und eigentlich willst du halt, wenn du Dinge umsetzen willst.
Willst du das eigentlich mithilfe von auch Verbündeten tun oder willst du,
dass Leute halt auf deiner Seite stehen, während Trump sehr viel tut,
um potenzielle Unterstützer vor den Kopf zu stoßen.
Und ja, einfach an Glaubwürdigkeit,
also seine Glaubwürdigkeit zu verspielen gerade und das ja,
Aus meiner Sicht macht es zunehmend unwahrscheinlicher, dass er erfolgreich
sein wird bei jetzt friedensstiftenden Maßnahmen.
Meinst du generell friedensstiftenden Maßnahmen auf der ganzen Welt oder jetzt
konkret in dem Falle von Ukraine nur?
Ja, generell bei allem, was da durchsetzt wird, aber speziell jetzt auch in
der Ukraine, aber auch was er im Gaza jetzt tut,
ist auch gerade hochgefährlich, weil wir sind ja in der Mitte von einem Deal,
sind noch immer nicht alle Geiseln ausgetauscht.
Da ist halt auch gerade ein wackeliger Waffenstillstand und dort rein zu grätschen mit der Ansage,
ja die Palästinenser sollen sich woanders niederlassen als im Gazastreifen, da ist eh alles kaputt.
Ja, ich meine, dass er diese ganzen komplexen Zusammenhänge der Weltpolitik
nicht versteht, das ist ja jetzt nichts Neues, das weiß ja auch jeder.
Also am Ende muss man glaube ich auch nicht das, was er jetzt gerade erzählt,
so ernst nehmen, weil ich meine, die Methode Trump ist ja bekannt.
Er haut halt irgendwas raus und es geht nur darum, dass alle über ihn reden
und dass alle irgendwie über irgendwas reden und alle permanent in Shock and Awe sind.
Das funktioniert ja soweit auch ganz gut. Dass er wirklich eine kluge Politik
an den Start kriegt, um seine Ziele zu erreichen.
Dafür gibt es, glaube ich, relativ wenig Belege aus seiner letzten Runde.
Das Kernproblem ist, dass es ihm glaube ich im Wesentlichen eigentlich nur darum
geht, sich an allen zu rächen, dafür zu sorgen,
dass seine Familie und seine ganzen Kinder und Nachkommen sozusagen die nächste
Machtdynastie in den USA darstellen und dass er sich eben maximal bereichern kann.
Und dabei braucht er natürlich auch ein bisschen Unterstützung,
die bekommt er jetzt von diesen ganzen libertären Tech-Pro-Rassisten wie Elon
Musk und Peter Thiel, die jetzt derzeit erstmal tun, was sie wollen,
ohne irgendwie in irgendeiner Form zur Ordnung gerufen zu werden.
Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so lange gut gehen, weil ich mir denke,
da wird dann in den USA auch eine Gegenbewegung einsetzen.
Ich weiß noch nicht ganz genau, wie die aussehen wird. Ich weiß auch nicht genau,
wie erfolgreich die sein wird, aber die wird auf jeden Fall da sein.
Und in dieser ganzen Gemengelage wird sich dann eben Schritt für Schritt in
irgendeiner Form auch eine Ukraine-Politik abzeichnen. Nur...
Pro-Russisch in dem Sinne sind sie jetzt nicht mehr.
Es gibt in diesem Magerlager im Prinzip zwei Fraktionen.
Es gibt halt die, die jetzt sozusagen noch auf der alten Propagandawelle mitlaufen
und irgendwie noch nichts davon gehört haben,
dass das sozusagen ja alles nur Propaganda war und das irgendwie wirklich glauben
und deswegen jetzt immer noch irgendeinen Putin-freundlichen Unsinn von sich geben.
So Tucker Carlson und solche Vollhonks. Und dann gibt es halt sozusagen diese
republikanischen Realisten,
die sagen wir mal in ihren politischen Zielen jetzt auch nicht sehr viel genießbarer
sind, aber denen es halt einfach nur darum geht, irgendwie maximal Reibach zu machen.
Und Trump will halt einfach zu den Gewinnern zählen. Er will halt irgendwie
mit den Tollsten sein und so weiter.
Und seine ganze Diktatorenliebe kommt ja auch nur davon, dass er eben so Leute
toll findet, die halt irgendwie alles unter Kontrolle haben.
Und in dem Moment, wo Putin nicht mehr alles unter Kontrolle hat,
ist Putin für ihn halt irgendwie auch kein Ding.
Aber es ist natürlich das Problem, dass sie jetzt gerade sich selber so ein
bisschen selber die Finger abschneiden,
diese Säuberungen, die sie da jetzt gerade durchführen im juristischen Bereich,
aber vor allem auch im CIA Apparat und USAID runterfahren, weil Elon Musk sich
irgendwie für die Niederschlagung der Apartheid in Südafrika rechnen möchte.
Das ist natürlich überhaupt nicht klug. Also gerade USAID, ich glaube das verstehen
auch in den USA relativ wenige.
Das ist natürlich eine extrem wichtige Organisation für die USA,
um sozusagen ihre Credibility weltweit aufrecht zu erhalten.
Das wird alles dazu führen, dass sich viele neue Allianzen suchen werden.
Das wird den Chinesen sehr gut tun. Das wird, wenn Europa sich halbwegs klug
verhält, auch den Europäern wieder mehr Interesse zuspülen.
Von daher schwächen sich die USA an der Stelle auch.
Ob sie ihre Unterstützung für die Ukraine einstellen werden,
da habe ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel.
Weil ich glaube, dass Trump eher da quasi als Sieger dastehen will.
Dass das jetzt sozusagen im Raum steht.
Also Ukraine, entweder gewinnt es halt jetzt irgendwie Russland,
aber dann gewinnt es halt nicht Trump.
Ob sie die richtigen Maßnahmen einleiten, ob sie da klug vorgehen, muss man mal schauen.
Es gab ja jetzt einen angeblichen Friedensplan, der geleakt wurde.
Also da glaube ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig dran, dass der wahr ist.
Also dass der in irgendeiner Form ein Plan ist, von dem jetzt wirklich irgendjemand
davon ausgeht, dass der jetzt auch so durchgeführt wird.
Sondern das ist eher so ein bisschen die Niederschrift der bisherigen Propagandalüge,
die sie so im Wahlkampf gemacht haben.
So nach dem Motto, wir geben den Russen einfach immer irgendwie alles und dann
passt das schon irgendwie. So funktioniert das halt nicht.
Ich glaube, die Ukraine ist gar nicht so schlecht aufgestellt.
Zelensky hat sich halt sehr klug verhalten.
Er hat sich nicht jetzt nur auf Bidens Seite gelegt so im Wahlkampf.
Und war ja dann schnell auch am Start, Trump da irgendwie rechtzeitig wieder
in die Hand zu schütteln, also in virtuellen Art und Weise.
Und dieser Move zu sagen so, ja hier, also bei uns könnt ihr irgendwie eine
Menge Geld verdienen, wenn ihr uns helft, ist glaube ich gar nicht mal so doof.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt alleine entscheidend sein wird für die weiteren
politischen Schritte, die wir hier sehen, aber derzeit, denke ich mal,
stärkt die Ukraine ihre Position, weil sie halt auf dem Battlefield mit den
Angriffen, wie wir das ja geschildert haben,
Fortschritte machen, weil sie nach wie vor resilient sind, weil sie nach wie
vor die Region in Kurs halten, weil sie technologisch voranschreiten,
weil sie einen Plan haben.
Ich glaube, dass die Ukraine sogar
in dem Falle, wenn die USA ihre gesamte Unterstützung einstellen würde.
Wobei es gibt da verschiedene Level an Unterstützung.
Keine Waffen liefern wäre schon mal hart.
Keine Intelligence liefern würde sie vermutlich nicht.
Noch mehr treffen? Also diese ganze Luftraumüberwachung, Satellitenzuspielung,
Zulieferung von Intelligenzleute vor Ort, die im Land sind, die sozusagen Informationen bereitstellen.
Das ist sicherlich von sehr großem Wert und das ist auch etwas,
was nur die USA so leisten können, wo Europa viel zu schwach ist,
weil Bundeswehr kann es komplett vergessen,
Frankreich und UK, die können das, aber die haben halt einfach nicht ansatzweise
auch nur die Facilities und die Netzwerke und die Satelliten und die Airwax-Flugzeuge und so weiter.
Das hat Europa einfach alles nicht. Das existiert nicht.
Das ist nie gebaut worden, weil man halt immer gesagt hat, so ja,
auch die USA, die passen schon auf uns auf. Irgendwie passt schon.
Wir haben ja ein paar Kriegsschiffe, wir haben ein bisschen Atomraketen und
die Bundeswehr hat Geld und die bauen immer schon die Zelte und die Wasserversorgungsanlagen.
So kommen wir schon irgendwie klar. Und jetzt haben wir halt das Problem,
dass sich Europa im Krieg befindet und es sein kann, dass der größte Schutzpatron
einfach so, weil gerade die Laune umschlägt, mal aussetzt für eine Weile.
Das ist natürlich alles nicht gut für die USA und das ist auch nicht gut für
Europa und langsam wäre es auch immer an der Zeit, dass man in Europa da mal.
Das dann langsam mal so ein bisschen die Checkung einsetzt, so vor allem in
Deutschland, aber das dauert aber noch ein bisschen.
Ja, also gerade an dem Punkt sind,
Europa Europa hat theoretisch nicht alles,
aber fast alles und kann fast alles produzieren, was die Amerikaner auch produzieren
können, mit wenigen Ausnahmen.
Aber ich habe mir das jetzt mal angeguckt, auch durch sämtliche Waffensysteme
gegangen und es gibt für fast jedes Waffensystem,
egal ob du bei Kampfpanzern, Panzerfahrzeugen,
Artillerie,
Raketen, Luftabwehr, gibt es europäische Alternativen. Das ist die eine Sache.
Das zweite ist, was vielleicht nicht jeder weiß,
Frankreich ist sehr autonom, was Waffensysteme angeht.
Und die französische Rüstungsindustrie beschäftigt 250.000 Menschen.
250.000?
Ja, in Deutschland sind es ungefähr 100.000 nur. die deutsche Rüstungsindustrie.
Und mir ging neulich halt durch den Kopf, naja, wenn wir jetzt gerade so ein
bisschen Probleme mit der Automobilindustrie haben oder generell und eh klar ist,
Europa muss aufrüsten, hat Deutschland da erheblich Potenzial und Technologie.
Und eigentlich spreche ich jetzt nichts dagegen, wenn die deutsche Rüstungsindustrie
jetzt 300.000, 400.000 Leute beschäftigen würde,
um auch billiger Waffen für uns bauen zu können.
Weil wenn wir schon aufrüsten müssen, dann doch lieber mit zu Hause gebauten
Waffen, als mit welchen, die man im Ausland einkauft.
Das ist das Ding. Und das Problem ist halt, es dauert halt irgendwie immer Rüstung hochzufahren.
Also so eine Panzerproduktion, um die deutsche Panzerproduktion auf das Niveau
wie im Kalten Krieg hochzufahren, braucht es ungefähr zwei Jahre.
Ja, aber in zwei Jahren, wenn man heute die Entscheidung trifft,
wir wollen jetzt mehr Panzer bauen, also wir wollen jetzt 300 Panzer im Jahr
bauen, dann ist das in zwei Jahren zu schaffen.
Oder wenn man mehr investiert, kann man auch sagen, wir wollen,
wenn wir irgendwie 1000 Panzer pro Jahr bauen wollen, dann könnten wir das wahrscheinlich
in drei Jahren oder so könnte Deutschland 1000 Panzer pro Jahr produzieren.
Das waren auch, also zu Zeiten des Kalten Krieges, wenn man jetzt alles zusammenzählt,
so von Kampfpanzern und Artillerie und so, war die deutsche Panzerproduktion
auf bis zu 700 Panzern pro Jahr. So im Kalten Krieg.
Das ist also beispielsweise erreichbar.
Nur hat man eben, also wenn man vor zwei Jahren die Entscheidung getroffen hätte,
wir machen das, dann könnten jetzt dieses Jahr 300 Kampfpanzer in Deutschland vom Band rollen.
Tatsächlich werden es eher so um die 100 sein wahrscheinlich.
Was Deutschland produziert für die eigene Bundeswehr, für Ukraine, für alle anderen. Ja.
Das...
Aber so kann davon ausgehen, selbst wenn die USA sich komplett zurückziehen würden,
könnte Europa das nicht komplett auffangen, aber die Ukraine wäre nicht gezwungen,
sofort zu kapitulieren.
Ja, das kann man glaube ich auch festhalten.
Das heißt, das wäre zwar ein harter Schlag, aber wie du auch schon richtig sagst,
das wäre halt auch ein harter Schlag für die US-Rüstungsindustrie,
die sowieso jetzt durch Trump gerade Probleme bekommt.
Und die Äußerungen, wie gesagt, von Trump bisher, die haben Vertrauen zerstört
und werden konkrete Auswirkungen auf US-Rüstungsexporte haben.
Wovon natürlich die amerikanische Rüstungslobby alles andere als begeistert sein wird.
Das heißt, da ist zu erwarten, dass dort jetzt auch in Kürze Gegenwind aus dieser
Richtung kommen wird gegen Trump.
Und das wird interessant.
Ich meine, auf der einen Seite, ich meine, es ist hart,
für wen man jetzt hier Sympathien hegen soll in dieser Auseinandersetzung zwischen
Trump und dem amerikanischen rüstungsindustriellen Komplex,
der ja schon auch eher irgendwie ein Ding für sich ist, der so gigantisch ist,
wie man sich das als Europäer kaum vorstellen kann.
Das sind 800 Milliarden im Jahr.
Das ist fast das Zweieinhalbfache des deutschen Bundeshaushalts,
der allein in Rüstung geht.
Und das Ganze ist ein Selbstläufer. Und das dürfte also auch interessant werden.
Und so Trump gegen amerikanischen rüstungsindustriellen Komplex.
Ja, vor allem das Ding ist ja selbst, nichts bei Trump folgt irgendeiner Logik.
Weil wenn du da mit einer normalen politischen Logik rangehen würdest,
dann wäre das Ding sowieso klar.
Denn was liefert die USA derzeit in die Ukraine?
Die produzieren ja nicht neue Waffen und schicken die dahin.
Sondern die Waffen, die die USA an die Ukraine liefert, sind Waffen,
die die USA bereits haben.
Und die liegen da rum. Und ein Großteil davon, wenn nicht fast alles, ist alt.
Und Waffen können nicht ewig rumliegen. Du kannst nicht eine Rakete ins Regal
legen und 50 Jahre später rausholen.
Die funktioniert dann irgendwann nicht mehr. und du kannst die dann aber auch
nicht einfach in den Mülleimer entsorgen, sondern du musst sie mit relativ großem
Aufwand rückbauen und sozusagen dekommissionieren.
Das kostet eine Menge Geld. Es ist sehr viel billiger, wenn du die Rakete einfach
in die Ukraine schickst und sagst, feuert die mal auf die Russen, das passt schon,
damit hast du sozusagen weniger Geld ausgegeben, weil du dir das Dekommissioning
sparst und muss natürlich für Replacement sorgen, aber für dieses Replacement
muss man sowieso sorgen.
Das heißt, die USA geben eigentlich gar kein Geld aus, was sie nicht sowieso ausgeben müssten,
aktualisieren quasi ihren Rüstungsbestand permanent, haben keine zusätzlichen
Kosten durch das Decommissioning von alten
Waffen und das ist eine Win-Win-Win-Win-Win-Win-Win-Win-Win-Win-Situation.
Und die aufzulösen ist vollkommen bekloppt. Also ich meine, selbst wenn.
Da kannst du komplett im Tramschen-Sinne mit America First und irgendwie Kohle
für uns und weniger Ausgaben für den Staat argumentieren.
Das ist genau das, was da passiert sozusagen.
Also es kostet eigentlich gar nichts. Es ist so mehr oder weniger ein,
gut, du hast immer noch die Logistik und sozusagen du musst es irgendwie auf
ein Schiff laden und darüber fahren oder hinfliegen.
Und das kommt natürlich noch dazu, aber das ist alles überhaupt gar kein Vergleich
zu dem, was das sonst kosten würde.
Das trifft wahrscheinlich auf die überwiegende Zahl der Waffen zu, aber nicht auf alles.
Also zum Beispiel die Abrams Kampfpanzer sind extra neu für die Ukraine produziert
und ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass auch bei der Munition und so und bei Luftabwehrraketen es Bereiche gibt,
wo dann direkt geliefert wird.
Aber der Großteil kommt wahrscheinlich aus amerikanischen Depots und da ist
tatsächlich auch noch eine Menge zu holen. Das ist so das andere Ding.
Also die amerikanischen Depots aus Zeiten des Kalten Krieges sind auch noch
voll, so im Gegensatz zu den russischen. Obwohl die Amerikaner auch viel abgebaut haben.
Ich hatte mir mal vor Jahren die Zahlen angeguckt, so bei Munition und so haben
sie auf die Hälfte oder ein Drittel abgebaut.
Aber das waren auch irrsinnige Zahlen, die die Amerikaner hatten.
Was weiß ich, bei Granaten irgendwie sich 20 Millionen Stück oder so.
Jetzt müssen wir mal langsam zum Schluss kommen.
Hast du irgendwelche Predictions am Start?
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Ob ich mich da groß beteiligen möchte.
Ja, ich meine normalerweise, also die normalen Gesetzesmäßigkeiten,
was ich glaube, wie die Welt funktioniert ist,
dass sich das schon irgendwie einmitteln wird.
Das sagen, egal was Trump oder was Putin wollen, nichts von dem wird so passieren.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es Trump gelingen wird, einen Waffenstillstand in absehbarer
Zeit, also nicht in den nächsten drei Monaten.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass allerdings die Verhandlungsbereitschaft der Russen
zunehmen wird in diesem Jahr,
aber nicht weit genug gehen wird.
Und ja, dann gab es so die interessante These auch noch,
dass die Situation gerade, was die NATO-Mitgliedschaft für die Ukraine angeht, die ja dann auch,
sagen die, eine große Frage bei jeder Art von Waffenstillstand oder Abkommen
ist natürlich die der Garantien.
Und Russland will auf jeden Fall verhindern, dass die Ukraine der NATO beitritt.
Das ist ja eines der großen Kriegsziele.
Und wenn ihr das jetzt gewährt werden würde, sozusagen Versprechen,
ja, die Ukraine kommt nicht in die NATO,
ist erstmal die Frage, wie viel ist so ein Versprechen von Trump wert?
Oder wie viel ist so ein Versprechen wert, einfach generell.
Und dann aber, okay, wie wird denn dann anderweitig garantiert,
dass der Krieg nicht wieder einfach aufflammt.
So wie stabilisiert man das Ganze.
Und da gibt es im Moment einfach keine glaubwürdigen Pläne auf dem Tisch,
keine glaubwürdigen Garantien.
Und der Punkt ist ja, dass eigentlich eine Garantie bereits existiert, eine vertragliche.
Die USA und Großbritannien haben ja seinerzeit garantiert die territoriale Integrität
der Ukraine im Austausch dafür,
dass die Ukraine ihre Atomwaffen abgegeben hat.
Ja, so, das heißt, mit irgendwie einem Stück Papier ist es nicht mehr getan,
weil das Papier existiert bereits und war halt, ja.
Wie gesagt, also so einfach wird es nicht gehen.
Und wenn es jetzt nicht zu einer NATO-Mitgliedschaft kommt, dann wird es auch
ohne eine Stationierung von US-Truppen in der Ukraine verfolgt.
Nicht gehen. Europa hat nämlich nicht genug Truppen.
Es wären ungefähr 200.000 bis 300.000 Soldaten erstmal notwendig,
die in der Ukraine stationiert werden müssten aus dem Westen.
Das kann Europa alleine im Moment nicht leisten.
Die USA und Trump wird keine nicht bereit sein, 100.000 oder 200.000 Soldaten
in die Ukraine zu schicken.
Auf keinen Fall.
Ja, das heißt, jeder Friedensplan selbst oder jeder Waffenstillstand,
selbst wenn einer zustande kommen sollte,
würde im besten Fall eine vorübergehende Waffenruhe bedeuten.
Und keine, also eine dauerhafte Lösung ist im Moment einfach nicht in Sicht
bei dem aktuellen Stand der Dinge.
Vor allem eine Einigung, wie auch immer sie dann aussehen mag,
muss ja auch die Zustimmung der Ukraine haben. Und ich glaube,
bei der Ukraine ist die Situation klar.
Man wird nichts akzeptieren, was in irgendeiner Form Verzicht aufs Land beinhaltet
und was keine solche Sicherheitsgarantien macht.
Und die NATO wäre ja nun auch schön doof, wenn sie nicht die Ukraine mit in
ihren Kampfverband mit aufnehmen würde.
Weil im Prinzip die Ukraine in der NATO, das ist der Nagel im Grab aller imperialen Pläne Russlands.
Weil Russland weiß, NATO mit Ukraine und Finnland und Polen und den baltischen,
Staaten sozusagen an ihrer Front, das ist für sie das metallische Ende jeder Expansionspläne.
Da werden sie keinerlei,
da haben sie einfach keinerlei Chance mehr. Das wissen sie auch.
Und ich glaube generell wissen sie auch, dass sie derzeit eigentlich relativ scheiße dran sind.
Und die einzige Möglichkeit, oder der einzige Grund, warum eigentlich überhaupt
Russland sich überhaupt noch halten kann in diesem Krieg.
Weil sie einfach nach wie vor das beste Game im Propaganda-War haben.
Ich erinnere hier an diese Nummer mit irgendwie Bauschaum in Autos in Deutschland,
in Auspuffe und dann noch irgendwie ein Habeck-Aufkleber aufs Auto drauf. Das ist so der Level.
Wir machen mal hier eure Glasfaserverbindungen und eure Stromleitungen kaputt
mit irgendwie so, oh, da ist uns gerade ein Anker runtergefallen.
Achso, das kann ja jedem mal passieren.
Also diese permanente Betrollung und diese permanente Bedrohung funktioniert
ja leider, weil wir dann eben so ausgeboten haben wie irgendwie Scholz, die einfach in so einer.
Ja oder Sarah Wagenknecht, okay das ist nochmal ein anderes Problem,
aber diese deutsche Angst vor irgendwie der russischen Übermacht und vor Atomkrieg
und so weiter, Das führt einfach nur dazu,
dass die Russen einfach vollkommen überbewertet sind.
Also wenn man sich einfach anschaut, welche Bedrohungen sie real für uns darstellen,
wenn wir uns nur mal wehren würden, dann sähe glaube ich die Betrachtung ganz anders aus.
Und auch Beidens Regime muss man jetzt vorwerfen, also seiner Regierungszeit.
Dass sie eigentlich total unterperformt haben.
Also sie haben sich völlig ins Boxhorn einjagen lassen.
Jede Eskalationsstufe, die immer irgendwie so, oh, wenn wir das machen,
dann bringt ja das passieren und so weiter. Was ist davon wirklich jemals eingetreten?
Nichts. Keine einzige Befürchtung ist jemals eingetreten.
Die Russen haben dem nichts entgegenzusetzen. Und wie viel Schiss sie haben,
sieht man ja auch sehr schön an ihrem ganzen Kommunikationsverhalten.
Das hatten wir ja eingangs schon erwähnt,
wie sie sich jetzt überhaupt der Trump-Regierung gegenüber verhalten.
Also noch wenige Tage vor Amtsantritt
war ja die ganze Zeit so in der russischen Propaganda so dieses,
ja unsere Ureschnik hier, unsere neue ICBM, unsere Long-Range-Waffe und da können
wir irgendwie alle europäischen Hauptstädte mit Atombomben beregnen und was
sie nicht alles für einen Unsinn von sich gegeben haben.
Ich meine, das ist Fernsehen und so weiter, das ist Propaganda,
aber wir wissen, das findet ja nicht unabhängig von der Kreml-Steuerung statt.
Kaum war Trump an der Macht...
Keiner redet mehr davon, irgendwie Atomraketen über dem Westen abzurechnen.
Also es ist einfach diese komplette Reschnick-Diskussion, wo sie sich wochenlang
einen drauf gewichst haben, ist sozusagen von heute auf morgen komplett weg.
London, Großbritannien wollen sie immer noch newsen.
Achso, doch noch.
Aus irgendeinem Grund hassen sie die Engländer wie die Pest,
also mehr als die Amerikaner noch. Weil hier Solowhef neulich, also ja, aber...
Wahrscheinlich haben die noch mehr Geld und mehr Yachten weggenommen.
Ja, Washington haben sie jetzt rausgenommen.
Also ich hörte, was wohl passiert sein soll zu Beginn des Krieges,
also nach Kriegsausbruch.
Und drohte angeblich wohl tatsächlich eine nukleare Eskalation.
Also die Russen wollten wohl tatsächlich taktische Nuklearwaffen einsetzen.
Und die Chinesen haben dann wohl einfach gesagt, nee, lass das mal.
Und die Amerikaner haben das halt alles mitbekommen.
Und das soll wohl der Hintergrund dafür sein, warum dann die beiden Regierungen
einfach Schiss hatte seitdem.
Ob das ein erfolgreicher russischer Bluff war, weiß man nicht.
Aber Fakt ist, dass sich wohl...
Die amerikanische Regierung den Eindruck hatte, Russland oder davon überzeugt war,
dass Russland Atomwaffen tatsächlich einsetzen könnte und das geplant hat und
eben, dass nur durch Intervention der Chinesen sie davon abgehalten wurden.
Und dass damit Putin es geschafft hat, so ein bisschen die Agenda oder das Framing
für den Rest von Bidens Amtszeit zu setzen.
Und ob das jetzt so gelaufen ist, es klingt auf jeden Fall plausibel.
Also ich könnte mir das vorstellen, dass da etwas in der Art gelaufen ist.
Ja, in Deutschland haben wir jetzt wieder Wahlen.
Was sagen denn so die einzelnen deutschen Parteien zur Ukraine aktuell?
Wen können wir denn wählen, um in dem Konflikt...
Da ist noch eine Wahlempfehlung abgeben. Also ich habe da eine relativ klare Meinung.
Ich glaube, es gibt nur eine Partei, die irgendwie eine halbwegs stabile Einstellung hat zu dem Thema.
Der Rest kann eigentlich weg.
Und verrätst du auch, um welche Partei es sich...
Na, du weißt, welche Partei das ist.
Ja, aber nicht zu 100 Prozent.
Das ist schon zu 100 Prozent, aber die Grünen sind die einzigen,
die vorher schon immer vor Russland gewarnt haben,
sind die einzigen, die irgendwie eine klare Haltung zur Unterstützung der Ukraine
von sich gegeben haben und denen es im Prinzip alles nicht weit genug ging.
Und an dieser Position hat sich generell nichts geändert.
Die Linken kannst du komplett in die Pfeife rauchen, was diese Position betrifft,
weil die halt irgendwie in ihrer Russlands-Liebetradition irgendwie da meiner Meinung nach….
Weil die nicht erkannt haben, dass Russland nicht mehr links und kommunistisch ist.
Ja, erstmal das sowieso. Ja, das ist halt auch so ein, wie ich finde,
ein bisschen von der Realität entkoppelter Prinzip-Pazifismus.
Also diese Vorstellung, man müsste nur ausreichend lieb genug sein und dann
würden die bösen Diktatoren schon irgendwie weichen, dem kann ich halt wirklich nicht folgen.
Nee, da gibt es dieses schöne Wort Unterwerfungspazifismus.
Genau. Und das bringt uns halt einfach nirgendwo hin.
Also es muss halt einfach einer Rechtsübertretung, muss einfach auch eine entsprechende
exekutive Maßnahme entgegengehalten werden, sonst findet das halt einfach immer wieder statt.
Und das ist halt meiner Meinung nach in diesem Ukraine-Fall einfach mehr als nur offensichtlich.
Und ich finde, wir haben eine moralische Pflicht, aber auch ein wirtschaftliches
Interesse und auch ein Überlebensinteresse daran, die Situation zu befrieden,
indem man halt den Aggressor zurückweist.
Und das geht halt einfach mal nur mit Force.
Was anderes gibt es nicht. Du kannst da natürlich jetzt anfangen,
irgendwie Blumen zu verteilen an der Front und so weiter, aber das machst du halt nicht lange.
Und gut, SPD haben wir halt gesehen, was das für ein Geeier war damit, Scholz.
Ja, es ist halt immer wieder drei Schritte zurück und vielleicht mal einen Schritt vor.
Die Partei ist auch viel zu sehr verstrickt mit Putin und dem Putin-System immer noch.
Genau.
Gut, CDU sagt zwar irgendwas, aber,
ich glaube nicht, dass Merz irgendeine nennenswerte politische Erfahrung nachweisen
kann, dass der in irgendeiner Form in diesem Spiel,
richtig mitgestalten kann und BSW und AfD kannst du eh komplett vergessen,
die sind einfach vollständig von Putin.
Sorry, aber so sehe ich das.
Ja, deckt sich weitgehend mit meiner Betrachtung.
Ich bin jetzt nicht so ein genereller grünen Anhänger unbedingt oder grünen Freund,
aber ich habe meine Probleme mit allen Parteien, weil ich halt zu viel Innenansichten erlebt habe.
Und das macht es für mich, also seit ich halt im Parlament war,
ist es für mich unendlich schwieriger geworden, Wahlentscheidungen zu treffen.
Vor der letzten Wahl hat es ja Annalena Baerbock schon im Fernsehen irgendwie
genau gesagt, was passieren wird und genauso kam es auch.
Aber tatsächlich muss ich sagen, ich bin generell so ein Underdog-Wähler.
Also es gibt immer irgendwie welche Parteien, wo ich das Gefühl habe,
dass sie ungerecht behandelt werden vom Wähler und von den Medien.
Und das sind dann, sagen denen, wo ich tendiere, denen meine Stimme zu geben.
Also oft sind das Koalitionsparteien.
Ich muss sagen, dass die Grünen aus meiner Sicht,
insbesondere Habeck,
einfach sehr klar unangenehme Dinge ausgesprochen hat, für die er dann zu Unrecht Prügel bezogen hat.
Und deswegen bin ich der Meinung, sie haben eigentlich in der Koalition einen
ordentlichen Job gemacht.
Aus der Perspektive der Ukraine und nur aus der Perspektive dieser Problematik.
Ja, also wenn Selenskyj sich sozusagen jetzt eine deutsche Regierung wünschen
könnte, dann wäre das meiner Meinung nach eine grün-schwarze Koalition.
Das ist sozusagen das, was die Ukraine sich wünschen würde.
Ja, Kanzler Habeck und irgendwie Merz wird natürlich dann, weil er zu wenig
Stimmen geholt hat, noch kurzfristig entlassen und durch irgendwelche erträglichen
Technokraten ersetzt oder man macht ihn zum Entwicklungshilfeminister,
oder keine Ahnung, was auch immer.
Der kann ja eigentlich nichts. und das würde wahrscheinlich irgendwie auch tatsächlich
eine Konstellation sein, in der ich denke, sogar Deutschland ganz gut von profitieren könnte.
Weil dann kann die CDU halt nicht wieder alles gegenwettern und sich irgendwie
mit der AfD verbünden, sondern muss das halt irgendwie mittragen.
Aber die Leitlinienkompetenz, die läuft dann zumindest schon mal in die richtige Richtung.
Naja, wünsch dir was. Wird nicht so kommen. Aber wäre natürlich etwas.
Ja, die SPD wäre für mich eine Alternative gewesen, wenn sie irgendwie den Pistorius
zum Kanzlerkandidaten gemacht hätten.
Der macht nämlich aus meiner Sicht, also von außen betrachtet,
eine ganz gute Figur als Verteidigungsminister.
Wahrscheinlich der erste Verteidigungsminister, soll es. seit Äonen,
der irgendwie eine gute Stikur macht.
Und das ist ein härterer Job als Kanzler. Also sagen, dem würde ich das durchaus auch zutrauen.
Und der gehört auch eher zu den Politikern, die sich nicht scheuen,
ich weiß nicht, zu sagen, wenn sie gerade irgendwas nicht wissen.
Und das ist so die Kategorie.
Ja, die ich einfach an Politikern mag.
Also Wurwereit war auch so ein Typ, der so Klartext geredet hat und eben auch
gesagt hat, keine Ahnung.
So wenn er keine Ahnung hatte, sondern das ist ein wichtiges Qualitätsmerkmal
und diese Souveränität,
weil dazu brauchst du einfach eine gewisse Souveränität,
das zu sagen und da mangelt es vielen an Souveränität Und ja,
Scholz, finde ich, geht einfach gar nicht. Den mochte ich noch nie.
So, seit ich ihn das erste Mal im Winterwahlkampf 2011 oder so.
Dieses Jahr haben wir auch wieder einen Winterwahlkampf.
Winterwahlkampf ist echt hart, so bei Minustemperaturen. Und es war in Hamburg
auch noch und da wehte dann ordentlich strammer Wind,
so mit leichten Minustemperaturen und du stehst dann draußen am Stand und versuchst
irgendwie mit Leuten ins Gespräch zu kommen.
Keine, ja.
Ja, naja, also ich denke, wir haben auch die Kraft, keine Ahnung zu sagen,
wenn wir darüber nachdenken, wann dieser Krieg beendet sein wird.
Ich habe zwar stark das Gefühl, man hätte schon genug Gelegenheiten gegeben,
diesen Krieg zu Ende zu bringen, aber dem ist halt leider bisher nicht so.
Ich denke wir können es an der Stelle jetzt auch mal gut sein lassen mit dieser
Ausgabe, wir haben ja schon wieder einiges zusammengetragen hier.
Ja.
Ich hoffe das war für euch informativ und interessant unsere Gedanken zu der
Gesamtsituation zu hören.
Schreibt uns gerne eure Kommentare bei uns ins Blog rein und zwar nicht um irgendeinen
Algorithmus zu befriedigen, sondern einfach weil uns das interessiert und eure
Sicht und eure Korrektur immer ganz, ganz, ganz wertvoll ist.
Ja, und wir werden weiterhin versuchen, das Geschehen möglichst nah zu begleiten
und werden uns dann demnächst wieder mal zusammenfinden.
Es muss nicht unbedingt mal drei Monate vergehen.
Das war jetzt leider so ein bisschen schwierig, einen Termin zu finden.
Aber ich denke mal, jetzt werden auch durch Trump so viele Dinge in Bewegung
kommen, oft im Guten und im Schlechten, dass es auch sehr viel früher wieder Update-Bedarf gibt.
Du erwähntest ja, dass auch der Wunsch an dich herangetragen worden wäre,
irgendwie eine Trump-Begleitung zu machen, aber ich glaube, das ist so schmerzhaft.
Ich habe schon diese erste Trump-Präsidentschaft mit Werbe und Intensität täglich begleitet.
Da bin ich so tief in dieses Rabbit Hole US-amerikanischer Innenpolitik und
Medienwelt eingestiegen. Das hat mir auch eine gute Basis gegeben,
überhaupt generell die USA zu verstehen und diesen ganzen Wahnsinn.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, das ist nochmal so eine Legislaturperiode,
da stecke ich lieber echt erstmal die Finger ins Ohr und sage, la la la la la la la la.
Das ist einfach alles nicht zu ertragen. Das wird einfach ganz schlimm werden
und da müssen wir irgendwie durch.
Aber es ist im Wesentlichen jetzt an den USA hier Reaktionen zu zeigen,
weil wir werden da nicht viel beeinflussen können.
Ja, nee, es ist auch schwer so.
Ich kann mich da leider auch dem Ganzen nicht komplett entziehen,
weil ich halt enge Freunde und Bekannte habe,
die auch davon betroffen sind.
Und deswegen ist das an mir näher dran, das Ganze, als vielleicht an allen anderen.
Aber ja, diesen Wahnsinn zu folgen, macht irgendwie nur verrückt.
Deswegen konzentrieren wir uns auf den anderen Wahnsinn. Ich würde lieber auch
noch mal ein paar andere Konflikte demnächst ein bisschen intensiver beleuchten.
Mich führt ja hier auf meiner Reise der nächste Schritt wahrscheinlich auch nach Taiwan,
dass die Perspektive aus chinesischer und taiwanesischer Sicht,
die pazifische Welt, die finde ich derzeit eigentlich viel interessanter.
Na gut, das war es jetzt. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und wir hören uns bald.
Alles klar.
Tschüss.